um you also have which was nice you know
if remember the last game had a partner
system which is a little light in that
like you know you're spawning on your
partner and then you're just kind of
running around but now there's like a
group and you get actually a bonus for
running around with your own group so
that's like four people and then a
couple that is obviously the hero system
which is still N and that uh yes so you
will see ray fighting Darth Maul and see
Han Solo young Han Solo fighting Darth
Maul that was some of the footage they
had yeah I mean I think the other cool
aspect of the hero system is that it
looks like they're introducing battle
points so in the game if you do well so
you get like five hundred battle points
you'll see a list and you're able to get
like a vulture droid right this is what
we'll see is the feed map which is on
the boo so it's prequel era which is a
very exciting actually and so yeah
you'll see like vulture droid and then
if you you know either you burn those
battle points or you hold on to them
till you get 5,000 and then you're
getting those heroes Darth Maul or Bubba
Fett you're seeing flying around and
stuff so yeah I hate to make the Call of
Duty comparison but it's kind of like
killstreaks and Call of Duty when you
have to call in UAVs or airstrikes or
you know the nuke if you're doing well
enough but um the first thing I thought
of - right exactly what it is so
something we did not see leaked today
Peter Brown was more of a single player
which we saw during the launch and I
know you're you were kind of tepid on
the first battlefront as well from DICE
um is that single-player stuff is that
what you want to see more of today and
throughout the week if that's what's
gonna pull you into Battlefront - yeah
absolutely i mean i think the
multiplayer was was okay in the first
game and I'd be happy to just have
access to like you know a newer version
of that with you know some of the stuff
you guys are talking about but for me
it's really the stories in the Star Wars
universe that that make me feel attached
to it so if I can get more of that I
mean that would be awesome
yeah and of course I will see more
battlefront - at the conference but of
course it's EA so we'll be seeing a few
other things that we know of battlefield
one dlc Rob you've kind of been on the
battlefield 1 DLC train from the
beginning since it launched last year
this is the in the name of the SAR DLC
so pretty big because they're
introducing the Russian army and the
Eastern Front right we're assuming some
snowy maps right like what are you
excited to see how this uh I think what
the coolest things about battlefield 1
is actually that like dynamic weather
yeah right
like just like seeing a
a sandstorm rolling in and then having
you know basically people shift to then
close range
Wow it changes your strategy yeah and so
as you said snow that's what they
mentioned so you can easily expect
snowstorms yeah so that could be pretty
neat
yeah Eastern Front you know they've said
vehicles I think some of the concept art
from I guess like a book or some like
that had like armored cars that were
used by both Germans and the Russians so
that works because as you know like a
lot of the vehicles in that game are
kind of shared so that makes sense in
that respect and then also any weapons
and I think they said a female character
you can play play playable female
soldiers for blur I think it's specific
to the Scout class which is almost
reminiscent of what we know about Call
of Duty World War 2 right where there is
that storyline about a believe a Russian
female sniper it's a French Resistance
sniper yeah Oh French excuse me yeah
well we won't say obviously we won't see
like World War 2 called a world war 2 at
the EA stage today but sorry um do you
think this could kind of get you amped
up going into called Duty World War 2
and releases later this year because
name in the name is our releases like
this summer yeah not too long after e3
ends like Howie do you play much
battlefield 1 or did you not get a
chance to I didn't get that she has to
play a lot of it but I kind of want to
jump into it with this DLC just because
I think that the Russian front is
especially under represented in media
and games in general I mean like I know
world war 1 obviously is not as
represented but I just think it's an
interesting area of the war to explore
so that's where a lot of my interests
lies in it and also I am very excited
that first for the series they're
introducing playable female characters a
multiplayer which is just something
that's near and dear to my heart
of course so I'm genuinely excited for
that yeah I think there's also concept
art that I saw internet ugly things
about gonna it's gonna ask you about
airplane so the snipers in that game
like they have like really cool like
capes yeah you're showing like this like
scout yeah welcome soldier with like a
cool like cap on that it looks pretty
tight so the fashion is what you're
looking for yeah go about it have you
seen any like airplane concept art that
you're excited about no not yet
Wow anyone see I wanna what what would
they do you know what Russians user and
what war - well sorry whatever one
planes did they
hey-ya is gonna be like some form of I
want to go do you think they'll be a new
behemoth no that was the other thing was
from the concept art was like a train
they had the Train behemoth already but
I get this one had like a snow plow oh
it looked cooler
oh that's cool like snowpiercer yeah you
see them like the Polar Express or the
Polar Express far less malignant thing I
was going over but very tough it uh Tom
Hanks is your conductor yeah sits on the
roof um peed you do you like coffee yeah
fate I might as well ask that's for the
shop but no I don't really know that
much about the game uh I actually did
not play these stories the short story
the war story sorry until a while after
release I played a lot of multiplayer
they got their work good um and I'm
excited to see what they might do with
that with this DLC okay is that unmanned
I guess they haven't said but they're
sorry in terms of in terms of like how
the multiplayer flushes out the story of
this game um but I mean have they said
they're not gonna do anything story-wise
of those war stories thing that's a
disappointment I would like to see like
Kelly's point it sounds like that would
be a good opportunity to yeah tell the
story on the other side of that war
rather there it yeah yeah the other
thing I think they'll they'll elaborate
on is like their premium friends system
and to which the point is like you know
I think these maps are locked for DLC as
and get the person or to play but if so
we'd say you have the jealousy and I
don't yeah in like an ugly situation is
that we're moving on from a map that we
both have and you get to carry on I
don't that system I think will allow me
at least one person in your group can
like carry on the group into an one of
the newer Maps sure I think but there I
don't I don't know much about that I
think they're gonna clarify how that
works right so you'll see more on the
battlefield ones DLC in the name of the
Czar which releases later this summer
not too long after e3 Need for Speed
payback we saw the announcement trailer
right and it seems a little bit
different than the last Need for Speed
we saw because last Need for Speed had
those corny like live-action Mike you
love it I like watching them on YouTube
yeah I mean it is a weird move yeah
let's be honest uh from the announcing
trailer they showed a it looks kind of
more like fast and furious action kind
of oriented it looks like they're going
for that because those movies will never
die but also it seems like they're
really avoiding those live-action
at least I would hope at least like they
showed not doing them this time yeah
that's that seems like the best approach
uh excited for a need for speed
payback at all yeah I like there's been
a lot of like really good simulation
heavy driving games over the past few
years but I feel like the arcade racer
has sort of like lost its like foothold
in the marketplaces
Need for Speed isn't always the best
example of that but um you know even
with the direction they're taking
regarding like all the stuff from
potentially fast to furious like that
sort of those themes that action that
could be good that could work well with
a need for speed I very fond memories of
playing the first handful of games up
through like the original like Hot
Pursuit so yeah I have some fun fondness
for Need for Speed you know we'll see
what they can do some gameplay some more
explanation would be great
I think they mentioned yeah as far as
like heavy chases with cops
I think people complain about like the
previous games being it making it too
easy to get away from cops I think they
hinted at like as far as ETA goes they
hinted at having different ways or needs
in order to get them off you by like
using environmental stuff I don't know
that's like plowing through like a
parking lot or like destructible
environment that matter yeah that seemed
interesting on them yeah we talked the
last week on the lobby our live show
about how it kind of looked a little bit
like Forza horizon 3 and the off-road
stuff in the Australian outback it looks
like yeah that you're kind of going into
these more off-road cars maybe like
these rally cars or something yeah the
use of the terrain instead of just the
roads and a complete fortune valley is
what they're calling it just uh you know
Las Vegas I know
Dandan they mentioned like and this
there's a story mode right they
mentioned three playable characters that
each kind of had to my understanding
like different traits right like you had
like your runner your have like a drag
racer I'm totally but and then baby
driver oh my god it's like a stunt
driver yeah yeah so I I wonder if that
would transfer over into like the
open-world right like you know you would
imagine an open-world would have
different quests and yeah events so
maybe those are obviously forced to had
that - is right you know just like you
know hit this jump to get experience and
whatnot yeah yeah I'm curious to see how
they'll actually take payback and kind
of expand on what they did with the last
game um I don't think there are too many
like EA Sports fans at this table are
there no no I like NHL games I've tied
until 94 if you want yeah alright let's
talk about it wouldn't think would you
want to see him take from NHL 94 that
goes into the new NHL mmm-hmm no I'm
kidding
um I do want to you were gonna Swabian
say nothing no I was gonna say it was
interesting with FIFA 17 they introduced
the the journey I kind of story driven
like actually not just the like a single
season kind of yeah yeah character and
everything is developing someone's
career exactly and uh I know it was kind
of FIFA 17 I think a lot of people had
thought I had a lot of hiccups but I
think the journey was a most interesting
thing it was last year at this time when
we saw it first right yeh showed it and
they're saying like oh it's this actual
character you're gonna guide through his
career you're gonna have him kind of
rise up through the ranks and I'm
curious they're gonna do that with FIFA
18 again or even with other ones NBA
Live or Madden 18 that's what I was
gonna ask you is if you thought that
they would kind of expand that into the
other sports games because it seemed to
be it was just such a good changeup
right like if you've been playing the
sports games for a while you kind of get
into the same rhythm it's nice to have
something new to do um so I imagine they
probably bring those to the other
franchises
if it makes sense you know I think
especially for Madden that would be a
big deal yeah I don't like know how well
that series sells anymore but like it
doesn't seem to be a game I hear talked
about among even my friends the way that
Madden used to be mm-hmm so I feel like
that series probably needs something new
to keep fans really
because that's one that really hasn't
changed that much yeah as far as I'm
aware yeah because I think last year men
17 had it really improved on a lot of
the minutiae which to be huge in a game
like an actual like sim game
ya know you have people settling into
these games and they play it for like a
year straight they're not necessarily
gonna want to just change the rulebook
you sure play on these these new rules
so yeah I think yeah probably need kick
in the pants in some way in the story
mode might be a if it's a thing yeah and
I'm wondering what they might do like
NBA Live
you know like see if they do introduce
some sort of I don't know character
progression with it or whatnot 2k hasn't
moved like that right yeah I'm pretty
sure okay
yeah seem weird I mean like yet remember
they remember the like face can yeah
yeah oh yeah oh geez yeah yeah you
talked to Phil years ago and you start
off with like your manager in like it is
a hotel relaxed game as well it started
off as like NBA face scan and put
yourself in a game that it became create
the most monstrous thing you can imagine
right there's a nightmare fuel that's
pretty bad um yeah I'm curious to see
what they'll be doing with those games
but another big thing I want to touch on
there been rumors well not of this
project Dillon from Bioware Bioware I
think it's safe to say is not having you
know like flagship year that's not the
phrase I know that but they're not
having a great year so far with Mass
Effect Andromeda uh they've improved the
game a lot substantially with you know
like the the animations people had
problem when it was kind of broken
overall I know like Jean Luc's I feel
like a lot in our office back at
GameSpot was just showing us these bugs
he encountered I came up on YouTube all
the time it seems like it would be a
year where BIOS Bioware so I might want
to stay quiet a little bit and maybe
like yeah no news is good news for right
now but when I thought yeah but you know
if this if they're really gonna show
this thing off and it can be super
impressive
that would be great they could totally
sort of overwrite like you know the the
damage I guess that Mass Effect did yeah
but we also got to keep in mind this is
a totally different studio work shares
thing yeah that was Bioware Montreal and
the IP is purportedly main studio in
Edmonton right yes and that would be and
then so a project Dylan for context for
people watching it's essentially the
rumor to be kind of getting into the
destiny
MMO a shooter action space action I like
new version game yeah
do you guys what's your prediction do
you think we'll see that at the
conference or this year or do you think
they'll wait on
I really hope we'll see it yeah yeah
because right now the only thing that
I'm really digging on is like Star Wars
maybe need for speed but I would love
something brand-new right like a new IP
that kind of thing would be great yeah I
mean I'm really hoping for those was it
other like 3 or 2 Star Wars games oh
right yeah exactly so land there's a
respawn motive right
oh yeah respawn and then EA motive is
sort of this battlefield battlefront and
then yeah you guys right visceral Amy
Hennig is the one she's working on
visceral right but I love it to you and
isn't that what started as Star Wars
1313 well that guy can and then this
studio come on I'd say it's more of just
like a if you follow the narrative of
Star Wars games being a fairy element I
don't know that there's any connection
of it okay gotcha
and those would be awesome to see yeah I
don't I don't think we would see
respawns right they seem really busy
sounds like it's super early they see
yeah and they seem really busy with
titanfall not I'm sure they have
splintered people to do titanfall 2 DLC
which you're not writing about I'm not
but it doesn't like actually speaking up
before I'm gonna ever do want to go back
to the Star Wars titles and Bioware but
do you think titanfall anything will
show up at the show you know I was
thinking about today um they could tee
something but I think it would be so so
down the road in that they just
introduced a new Titan which is like
fair pretty much a really big thing oh
the biggest DLC so far yeah as far as
like balancing a new Titan on the field
like I would want another new Titan cuz
I think they've hinted at a couple more
yeah though they remember they searched
someone found like mine the right logs
and found monarch which became this one
recently the most of it was Titan but
then bison was showing up is like a more
heavy class I think it had like a
grapple like a boxer yeah it sounded
this awesome yeah and then another
probably you would imagine then it would
be like a lighter class I don't know
kind of even out because now there's 7
Titans you imagine they'd at least go
for an even number maybe yeah I think
they yeah they definitely need to like
consider that the new Titan they have to
like balance that stuff but I also would
not be surprised I mean I would love a
teaser for something down the road yeah
yeah but going back to respawn I yeah
like I agree with Pete I would say it's
really early for that I mean yeah
they've even said recently that it's
very very early the Star Wars style yeah
yeah that they're just sort of in the
discussion
the phase you know at the planning yeah
so I imagine that's going to be a long
way off
all right see what like 13 15 seconds of
the visceral game he like walks out into
moss eisely I think yeah it and it looks
like as far as an era geez I guess I
would say like like a rogue one like
Empire at full swing right it was just
like you know those red flags like it
looks really neat pre a new hope um I
would definitely say so like you know
whether you're again I I got a lot of
the rogue one vibe of just like you know
you're an underground like a guy was her
name from the movie um swing jyn erso
jenner so you you know you're trying to
start a rebellion you're undermining the
empire that's what I kind of gathered it
be it would be super interesting if they
did go for that time period because you
know they had battlefront to which is
supposedly gonna be filling out you
smart rich and Jedi and force awakens
this could be the between a Revenge of
the Sith well much later after revenge
its if but maybe pre a new hope much
like rogue one was I would love that I
really liked rogue one a whole lot so I
would love to have a game that explores
that era too yeah but but yeah going
back to the Star Wars title at the
multiple ones that are in development
it's interesting to see that you know
Amy had a good visceral like knowing Amy
headaches past with Uncharted and her
like narrative focus games you're
assuming that would be the studio to
really tackle maybe a third-person
adventure action kind of game like story
driven you know to not to reduce her
work to just that but she's very good at
those narrative games right yeah and
then you look at respawn the only games
they've done or titanfall 1 & 2 but of
course they come from the Call of Duty
background Vince Zampella all those guys
there you'd assume this would be a much
more kind of focused action game right
and I'm interested to see how like the
juxtaposition between those works with
battlefront 2 which we know a lot more
about so I'd be interesting to see if
anybody comes to the show this year
outside of battlefront 2 it seems like a
big Star Wars here with episode 8 but I
think if anybody would be visceral yeah
I agree with that yes yeah but going
back to the Bioware thing yeah um it's
interesting to see or to hear from the
rumors that they might be going into
that space with Dylan with codename
right now because in so far right now
division is the only kind of thing
that's you know been there to compete
with destiny in that kind of space and
those are the kind of games that you
know you get in and then it's more it's
almost like a platformer unto itself
it's not just one game like the division
you look at a year after
released its like massively improved at
least from people who played it all the
time you look at destiny with taken King
and improve rise of iron was kind of
just like a you know throw away
expansion I think but we know destiny
too is coming in September and be
interesting to see how Bioware whose
traditionally known for these story
driven RPGs is going to compete with
something like destiny too because like
you're gonna have to right yeah I mean
knowing it's Bioware they kind of might
have something up their sleeve I don't
know Kelly what would you even want to
see out of something if it does turn out
to be something like project dealing
what would they have to do because I
know you're a big destiny fan yeah I
played a lot of just name also big
Bioware fans so I would like to see
something that kind of marries those two
things that's like strong on gameplay
but also has a strong narrative cuz
that's the one thing that was missing
for me and destiny as the narrative is
so barry like the lord that is there was
in the grimoire and if you were like
really intense you would like read the
grimoire on your phone or whatever which
i did but uh gotta get somewhere but i
would like there to be kind of a balance
between those things I'd like to see um
the RPG elements that I really like uh
you know even if they're distilled down
I would like to see that married with
like strong action gameplay and a
narrative I think by work could pull
that off I would like to see that I
would really hope that they wouldn't be
quiet this year I'm you know because
like Andromeda was a you know a misstep
to say the least but uh I don't think
that means they can't bring anything I
think would be better for them to show
something off sure Iran did you play a
lot of Bioware games back in the day or
um Mass Effect right you talk about mass
spec a little bit yeah Mass Effect uh
for Nexus I'm just thinking about like I
mean you mentioned like competing like
this thing would have to come out like
you got destiny to coming up right like
yeah come like at some time like way
down the road yeah it's yeah curious I
mean like destiny to I'm sure we'll
still have legs going far into next year
my if it's anything like the first
destiny with expansions or just you know
regular players to say the least but
yeah I mean they have to do some
different right yeah like whether that's
like a third person pole or yeah I mean
heavy stories what I guess I would I
would want right like yeah or like
creating your own path yeah we curious
about the tech behind it because
like there's a bunch of stories recently
about the development of Andromeda why
it was so difficult part of that is
because the development was so fractured
among different teams but also it was
the limitation of the Frostbite engine
while it's really good at doing some
things it's not good at doing
large-scale worlds okay and that created
the biggest problem for them so it's
gorgeous for like Battlefield Maps right
but yeah or come from yeah yeah but if
you're going to go for something that is
very large right with like a lot of
things to explore like it sounds like
the Frostbite engine might make that a
little bit difficult so maybe that's the
lesson the biggest lesson learned from
dromeda is to not do that and that might
that sounds like you know if the
development can go smoothly and you've
got Bioware's best people on it it could
compete with destiny in some ways but
it'll still have a Bioware twist right
in terms of how it delivers its story
then that's really be the thing that
puts it above and maybe even in a
different category and destiny too right
I think you and I were actually pretty
similar with destiny and the division
you know we try him out played in a
decent mount but then kind of fell off
unlike a lot of people interest in our
office you know like Eric hey jean-luc
play a ton of destiny
and the division but you know like what
would it be that kind of narrative like
do you think that the Bioware tackling
that space might be something actually
get you into that kind of game regularly
yeah but yeah I would hope so because
again like this stuff in destiny was
interesting you know to read it even
just simple item descriptions gave you a
lot of info on things in minutia so like
there is room in that space to do it and
I just voting exactly what Callie said
we just got to bring it to the forefront
and put it out there and that's
Bioware's strong suit yeah yeah I'm
looking forward to everything like
what's the last thing buyer has done
outside of like an RPG narrative space
like anything I mean if they did then it
didn't catch my attention because I just
I live for their RPG stuff I love to
kotor you know they've talked about this
a lot but if it's not Jade Empire - I
don't care ok sound alright so Kelly hmm
hit us with like what's your your wolves
wildest dream for this press conference
what do you want to see alright
necessarily like a new game around
talking about but like whether it's from
battlefront 2 or something that we
didn't talk about I we talked about a
lot of the big things I am also a huge
Sims fan oh hey my my wildest dream is
for there to be a good sense game set I
did not like Sims 4 yeah and I like I go
through urges where I like I'm like
to play the sims right now like it's
like a weird addiction that I have and I
love it it was like my favorite thing
yeah us so if they if they said anything
about the Sims and I would be a very
happy person probably in the minority I
know it's not a popular option but I
would like to see that what makes us in
getting good like what's that one thing
you're waiting for them to like attach
to that series well one of the things I
didn't like about for is that they
closed off the world so in three like it
was all real time and so you could just
kind of wander around and like the NPC's
would just be doing stuff and you could
kind of like zoom in and like there'd be
perky weird Sims garbage going on the
kind of stuff that Sims fans really like
and then in The Sims 4 I was like your
house was isolated and they added these
emotions to it that just kind of made it
like you had to micromanage what you
were doing and then if you wanted to see
anything fun happening it you had to go
through like several loading screens so
they just closed it off a lot with with
four so I'd like to see them kind of go
back to the roots of just the Sims being
about funny microcosm stories of like
weird stuff going down and houses
getting on fire and people drowning in
pools you know you are sued the usual
yeah like real life you know Robert
about you ah probably have to say
Battlefront - yeah I wanna won't have a
multiplayer experience and like yeah
stick with me through the test of time
yeah cuz the first one was just a lot of
spectacle surface appeal then you start
digging down deeper unless you mean like
you yourselves a die-hard Star Wars fan
oh this all thing it's like what I took
you for no reason uh yeah even you after
that initial like spectacle of this is
awesome I feel like I'm in a Star Wars
movie this universe kind of faded away
after a while
you hope like to has legs to carry it
through like past the first five hours
totally uh and the other thing is uh I
will always go to it
I love spaceships in Star Wars yeah and
it's nice to hear that criterion
criterion cry Sirian criterion excuse me
they did that VXR ring mission yeah they
like it was really great experience but
they told me that they had built the
flight controls from the ground up cuz
the flight controls and bow from like a
real spaceship huh they built a like a
real spaceship until the Kerbal space
program but they don't do this to me
sorry I mean to derail you they they
rebuild that the controls for the
spaceship so it's like that is now
incorporated into balford so awesome
yeah so I'm I'm just hoping for a kind
of revamp of that I know they have
mentioned like they're going to have
more of those like strict space battles
that will involve like dreadnought ships
like capital ship so you would have to
take down like asteroids a lot of
obstacles I wanna see a lot of that but
and that sounds great but I really want
to see more of like a reason to be
flying like a starship
with the ground in mind and of course
getting into a spaceship you can get
into a spaceship yeah I'm in Pete what
about you I'm kind of curious about
stuff we haven't talked about yeah like
some of the indie game stuff yeah hey
might be doing um
yosef airs brothers tell to sons which
was published by star breeze back in
2013 if I'm not mistaken he tweeted
recently he's coming to e3 and then a
couple years ago EA announced I think
during e3 that they would be publishing
his next game so brief teaser don't
always call but I was on the train
so don't think it's unlikely that we'd
see that today yeah that'd be cool you
know EA like a lot of publishers you
know they're great for their big titles
but smaller stuff matters and especially
if they're putting money behind it and
using creators you know like the guys
behind uh brothers yeah yeah did you
play brothers tells I'm two sons a
little bit and have a brother to play it
with I saw yeah
do you know did between stick stuff yeah
was a really great game uh yeah cuz he's
a film director a Swedish film director
then he got just felt like getting into
games and then Starbreeze took a chance
let him make brothers yeah from what I
recall the teaser trailer that published
in 2014 I believe we have on GameSpot
but we can you know like you could see
that there was some sort of just it was
a nighttime landscape there's someone on
a train and then that was it almost it
was just like I can't member it see
yourself know there look two guys like
in the excuse me in the like cargo area
of a train like like though aways yeah
it looked like kind of the stereotypical
like drifters like kind of hopping on a
train there was a couple props in the
foreground when the camera zoomed out
you could see like a mining helmet and
there was like another tool there so
maybe you know there's
kind of prospectors or something I don't
know okay cus chickens and what hear the
sound of a chip book - [ __ ] uh yeah so
I'm hoping to see something from Joseph
Ayers but uh does he have any other
indie projects that they're public about
yet I'm gonna know of because they
really they were they backed um
unraveled pretty heavily right yeah what
was well yarny yarny I just said Woolley
what am I thinking of
that's woolly world nice no I'm thinking
other thing you could draw that guy's
eyebrows with oh yeah wooly Willy yeah
some smaller titles as well but yeah I
would have to say if visceral does show
up and show something for Star Wars
outside of Battlefront - I don't think
it's likely but I would think it would
be pretty awesome to see that happen but
yeah I want to see more from I might get
back in a battlefield one once I finish
like a slew of really good games that
have happened this year because and the
name is are comes out you say I mean
maybe it's too much well I'm gonna have
to cut you off if you're watching on
YouTube or twitch or GameSpot that was
our pre-show we are getting into the EA
press conference right now we'll go over
there but stay tuned we're going to do
another post show right after EA but for
now let's go check it out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Devon I cover your career to University
of Texas would you disappear to
today is the day that we prevent this on
the NFL map long shot from the depths of
the unknown to being drafted by an NFL
team
all eyes on you this is stop you from
hightailing again let me ask you
something why are you here
good football is my life
my father used to say when the road
knocks you down get that double gate
waitis miles behind lawns up move you're
here today you're not the only one
trying to get traffic never wait at the
line for the final play of the game its
biggest moment of your life let's go out
there and prove to were that we belong
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
but round of applause for the drumline
guys that's Madden like you've never
seen it and I might be biased but I'm
pretty sure that's the most innovative
Madden we've done in well over a decade
welcome to EA play 2017 coming to you
from the Hollywood Palladium this is our
second year at EA play last year we went
out on a limb trying to do something a
little different with a view to changing
the way you interact with products
before they launched we wanted to to do
something that put the games in your
hands earlier and it showed us how much
further we can go as you can see we've
built a creative space here we're right
in the middle of it this is going to be
where it all goes down over the next
three days playing creating and sharing
with the rest of the world we've built
it this way for a very simple reason we
want more of you to be able to
experience this moment for thousands of
in Hollywood this week we have hundreds
of stations for hands-on gameplay and
for tens of millions of you out there
joining online from across the world
you won't hear it just from us you'll
hear it from players right here they're
here to see new things to ask questions
to challenge us to tell us what they
like and especially what they don't
they're going to connect with each other
and create content and of course they're
going to play as many games as they
possibly can so let's set the stage for
what we'll do over the next hour and a
bit we're going to go deep into eight
new experiences each with major reveals
massive innovation and stories that will
pull you in two years ago we launched
Star Wars Battlefront and we got a lot
of feedback a lot of it positive and a
bunch of it constructive
and to euphemism for not as positive so
today we're going to bring you 30
minutes of Star Wars Battlefront 2 and
what we hope you'll see is that we've
addressed all of the feedback and gone
even further we've got a mix of
everything here for you a look at new IP
some killer new trailers demos and a
bunch of live gameplay this is going to
be a lot of fun and it should be right
because we're all here for one simple
reason all of us share one fundamental
belief and that's that games are the
best form of entertainment on the planet
yeah they connect us like nothing else
they bring us together across cities and
countries they inspire us they ignite
the fires of competition inside us games
allow us to do extraordinary things and
to be extraordinary in our own ways
games enable us to be our most creative
selves well that's as game makers trying
to pioneer new ways to play or players
making each game a unique expression of
our own passion for what we do games put
the power of play in our hands to do
with it what we want and to make it our
own so let's celebrate for the next
three days we're here to celebrate play
with all of you and what better place to
start than with a game that has taken
the world by storm battlefield 1 there's
yeah there's more than 20 million
battlefield 1 players out there today
and we've got a lot to share about a
revolution that's coming to this great
franchise so let's jump to battlefield
right from the creative heart of EA play
hey everyone I'm Andrew Golota producer
for battlefield one at our dice studio
right here in LA I'm standing inside the
creator cave at EA play where your art
community is creating new content to
share with players across the globe it's
unbelievably rewarding to see more than
20 million players embracing the game
crafting their own memorable moments
only possible in battlefield 1 let's
take a look
hey new I got some questions to ask you
ok
what is it about the Battlefield
franchise that's so special and
appealing to you the thing I find
special about battlefield is teamwork
I'm not gonna shooting sometimes I like
to repair or heal or hide
I just shot an airplane out with McGahee
bowling I'm most definitely proud to be
a part of the battlefield community I've
never been a part of any other gaming
community where people are just so
passionate about their games everyone in
this community is focusing on making
this game as best as it can be and
expanding on the experiences that we've
already had last weekend better view
back I said is to heat a bunt writer and
dignity he doesn't be a clean-cut
player vs. tank versus plain versus
environment my most memorable moments is
what I do is my community
a sixty four minute arm that just does
massive crazy things I have made so many
amazing friends who have become more
like family it's something that brought
a whole wall people together we will
squad up and put a toe up
[Music]
Oh got a roadkill
[Music]
I'll never be able to do that again in
my life I'll never be able to do that
again in my life never ever that's it
that's as good as it gets I should just
stop playing I should quit
he just disabled a moving truck with a
grenade while jumping off a horse
incredible we love these only in
battlefield moments and we want even
more of them so we're bringing more ways
for you to play first night Maps debut
this summer in neville knights and
pleased it to her you'll need to deploy
tactics as you fight through the night
in a massive network of trenches second
I'm excited to announce a major
revolution in battlefield one we're
bringing epic battles to the Eastern
Front of World War one in the name of
the Czar expands battlefield one to the
blistering winter in the east this is
the biggest front of world war one and
with it we're bringing you six new maps
the Russian army including the mighty
hussar cavalry new vehicles and weapons
to expand your arsenal and the iconic
women's battalion of death finally we're
introducing a richer gameplay experience
in both progression and operations mode
by bringing deeper player progression
through all new assignments the ability
to tailor your play style with
specializations and new multi battle
experiences woven through the fan
favorite game-mode operations all of
this coming in September as part of in
the name of the Czar and for the next
three days the LUP kal pass map from in
the name of the Czar is right here at EA
play for those of you tuning in you'll
get a glimpse of it from these guys when
they share it on their channels very
soon so there you have it eight new maps
in total opening up the largest front in
World War one with new ways to play
there's never been a better time to be
part of the battlefield community now
enough of me let's give you a first look
at in the name of the Czar a revolution
is coming
was Lucius grow if spumoni shabam you
Paulo's kinivo budet Dior de ré a
certain budget [ __ ] doctor
voguing you
hi everyone I have the privilege of
leading our global development teams
6,000 of the most creative people making
truly amazing experiences including
battlefield one now this summer is going
to be huge so much new content so much
more to play and so many new ways to
play and there's one more thing we'll
bring to battlefields later this year
we're going to give you a new
competitive battlefield experience we've
heard you you want a smaller tighter
experience focused on team play you want
all-out war built for competition and
you want it accessible to players and to
viewers and it's coming I can't wait to
share more with you guys at Gamescom in
August now competition is at the center
of EA today and we've always thought
about it a little differently we believe
in making stars of all our players let
me tell you something really cool last
month I was watching an amazing
competitor Shell's he made it to the
[ __ ] championship finals in Berlin six
months ago this guy was an unknown now
he's a worldwide star and he'll be
competing with the best at the FIFA
interactive World Cup final in August
now we want to find more stars so we're
doubling down in competition in weighs
only EA can this fall we're launching
the largest FIFA championship ever with
many ways to compete the best [ __ ]
players will compete in the FIFA
Ultimate Team Champions Cups and in our
official football league competitions
you can represent your favorite real
world team
it's true you can will have much more to
share including our madam plans later
this summer as developers your passion
is what fuels us your stories inspire us
and competition like nothing else brings
them to life this is my first time first
time my first time this is my first time
competing I just thought maybe this is
something I could do
so many cosplayers I want to beat them
just like they want to beat me I just
don't understand how people think I'm
the underdog it's going to destroy that
this is the highest level you can play
there is a real thin line between
success and failure how nervous are you
right now it's gonna be a really tough
game I'm never gonna lose ever in my
life he's as a person you can hate
he is an absolute thief I wonder if
we're gonna see a handshake nope not
gonna see it he's come up at second
place time and time again
the time to stand up
this is what competitive gaming is all
about
we're about to crown a new king he's
lucky that is your champion Michael
Skibbe is your man 17
[Applause]
were you ever in doubt in that game I
was in doubt the whole time these guys
are going through something special
right now ladies and gentlemen sitting
on your couch this could be you
[Applause]
[Applause]
my team there's no agony I bring in
don't you see when can you go
no don't show up to my show if you've
got no
[Music]
now that you either Hey I don't want no
bad energy man give used by Rage arc of
the Cross see my enemy
Laffy Taffy girls melons and melons she
wants a man from London she was
my team there's no rat in it I bring it
on my team that's when they saw my team
even the bouncers bounce when they saw
my team
you want to never know don't be a seat
when you can be the go hungry is a big
time and you never know she don't show
up to my show with you god no
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
energy
yeah yeah yeah
who's in the mood
yo
[Music]
[Applause]
now everybody
come on everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
I went early Raj I went early ladies in
general we are the men in Blazers
that's Raj the bald one I'm Dave Oh way
less bald in person we are delighted to
be here how we really are some of you
will know us as a host of one of the top
three most popular football shows ever
to be produced in the panic room and the
crap part of Soho that is true somehow
we convinced world leaders like Will
Ferrell to come talk to us about the
fifth best sport in the world we've
tricked them all Dave oh yeah and the
common thread for us is always football
and FIFA and when I speak to players
around the world they all tell me their
experience Rafi forerun so deeply it
actually impacts the way they play on
the field that is art influencing life
it's all melding together rods look at
this look at how the world's game comes
to life in FIFA 18 player personality
that differentiates even the tools from
the smalls
they've even perfected the inimitable
run style of Raheem Sterling and develop
with detail Anton Griezmann technical
ability to suavely part fly past all
defenders and so SWAT and these
atmospheres Roger take a look at this I
make it feel like you're in the
Argentinian son with your pasty white
legs and this is massive ROG they've now
got the ideal athlete helping to develop
the game is to anyone better and more
genetically sound than Cristiano Ronaldo
could you get anyone better than that
that man doesn't have a six-pack he's
got an e pack you're right an EA Sports
know the only way to make Cristiano look
better to jam him in spandex and capture
his data
that beautiful man he's only oh let's
hear back-to-back champion of Europe
yeah the La Liga title Rwanda all we're
literally every trophy a most impressive
for our perspective that beautiful head
of hair he has hair Roger
but as huge Ronaldo has been this past
year there's one story bigger than them
all oh yeah Peter more becoming CEO at
Liverpool good look without on mate yeah
no no
Niraj the biggest story in football is
of course Alex hunter the new hero of
the virtual pitch and the star of the
journey the journey Alex would go on to
score more than 360 million goals in his
first season that one's true and so is
this one whenever your good old English
national team take the field over the
past year yeah the single name most
tweeted yeah more than Sir Harry cave
yeah
Alex hunter yeah we could have used him
today ROG
we could have won it all yeah talking
about winning it all though what a story
but you're Alex hunters have yet winning
the FA Cup just 18 years old barely
passed his bar mitzvah has experienced
more in his first season than I will in
my entire life that is true it was such
art to a truly amazing journey but the
life of every footballer is a journey
filled with victories defeat glory and
conflict dreams come true and challenges
that lie ahead so everyone wants to know
what is next for our man Alex hunter I
don't know Dave oh but it seems like
everyone's got an opinion there is one
question on everybody's lips next for
hunter everyone's hunting hunter Alex
hunter butyl
quickness just paper talk come on Sylvia
Alex hunter lies in the bundesliga
vanish be wisest I think that all right
and there is a Robert Allen Hughes Talon
he needs the right Club and the right
manager any couple developers having
Alex hunters in the media every day and
getting annoying to be fed Oh
eight-eight what kind of clubs with let
Alex hunter go I'm not really sure that
a move surviving for stuffing a function
but it's got their two victories boots
black I'll accept that it's a great
place she's a piece that she's very
quick got skill amazing skills
I'm telling us I can't the phenomena oh
please got to take around you does bump
these branching years to look after
himself go go I was no rumors have got a
stop yeah well I think some I'm really
out wasted dad will Alex hunter stay or
go
you should ask what about story you
happiness is enough for life does your
heart tell you
[Music]
[Music]
whatup guys thank you for having me ei
if you guys don't know who I am my name
is jesse wellens and i am a YouTube
creator so I am here to talk about Need
for Speed payback if you guys didn't
know HP payback I'm but um yeah it's
great game but I all set aside I'm a
YouTube creator deep speed paybacks
coming out I got my boy Marcus executive
producer here he is the producer in the
game Thank You NIC for having me hey man
thanks Jesse obviously we're really
excited to tell everyone about neat
replay back here today but more
importantly show it in payback you are
on a revenge mission to take down the
house house it's a cartel that rules the
city's casinos criminals and cops and
that is delivering it we're delivering a
brand new experience with wild heist
missions intense core pursuits grueling
car battles and jaw-dropping action
moments no longer sits just being about
being first across the finish line we
are putting you behind the wheel of an
action driving fantasy so these two
speed has been around for a long time
there's been a lot of new things coming
to the game and a lot of old things that
people are familiar with the franchise
exactly you know we're putting a new
narrative into the game where you drive
three different characters Tyler Jess
and Mack all bring their own unique
playstyle to the game you drive across
city mountains deserts and canyons in
the most diverse open-world ever made
for an equal speed game there's a lot of
great new elements in this game but also
obviously a lot of fundamentals like
customization we go way deeper when it
comes to visual before with visual and
performance customizations as well as
introducing something on top of that
something we call the relics which are
abandoned classic cars that you
transform from scrap to stock to
supercars speaking of customization my
homie Nick AR 12 game he looks like he's
customizing a classic beetle he's going
to be doing a lot more of this
zatia and gameplay at 1:30 on the stream
if you want to come back but enough
talking about it I'm trying to see it
yeah you know you know we're absolutely
very excited to show you the first one
of the blockbusters from needlessly
payback call the highway heist that show
starting tense action driving experience
so let's turn around and take a look
Koenigsegg Agera 0 to 60 in 2.7 seconds
we intercept then grab the car there
it'll be part of a convoy what are you
thinking quick hit and run get me close
to the truck and I'll take care of the
rest
we're hit the tunnel
[Applause]
get rid of these guys
that's what I'm talking about let me
give that me
damnit
[Music]
what the hell this guy's out of his mind
there's something much bigger going on
here
boy forget the tunnel we get him before
I reach the city
guys more cards away
tougher freakin times is what they off
they're going down either way
coming up fun just I've got a really bad
idea
bladder on the side get up on his right
never Jess do it
[Music]
I got this
that's what I'm talking about good job
Pete let's take it baby oh let's see
what she can do
okay boys let's even the ah I can ensure
that players as well as it looks last
year at ei play we unveiled ear
originals the program was something we
created to support small independent
studios shall bring experiences that are
unique gorgeous innovative and memorable
to the world we are partnering with game
traders through the process from
development to marketing to publishing
but ear originals is also about funding
or offering a level of security the
profits from these games go back to the
hands of the developers we have been
overwhelmed with the in the community's
reaction to this I can tell you we've
received hundreds four pitches many of
them brilliant and as a result we now
have several new titles in development
today I want to introduce you to our
next EA originals title one that I've
been very close to from the beginning
this game tells the story in an entirely
new way now a few years ago I played the
indie hit brothers a tale of two sons
with my oldest daughter
I loved how different the game felt the
mechanics and storytelling were really
cool and we both loved the emotional
story so I decided to contact the game's
creator Joseph Farris when we met we
instantly realized we share the same
passion for games and how to bring new
experiences to players I also found out
that he was building a new studio called
hate light now were thrilled to be
working with Joseph to bring his new
project to all of you what started out
as a wild idea on paper has now turned
into a groundbreaking one-of-a-kind game
called a way out take a look
what's your plan stay the hell away from
me
okay I'm sure you have good reasons to
bust out of here but I need to get out
of here too
yeah not my problem it's pitch black
we need a life screw it I'll go first
oh you okay
you have a problem I got a problem with
you
I love you buddy are you doing here
she's my daughter too
[Music]
see also come on leo
Hey
my name is Joseph Juarez Paris and I'm
the writer director of a way out I'm so
excited to be here and show you the game
so after I finished brothers I wanted to
make another game that push the
boundaries on how to tell stories
without compromising on gameplay and
this is the reason why I started his
light Studios together with the team
behind brothers and working with years
originals was perfect for this because
we have the full creative freedom and
trust from EA to deliver the game we
truly believe in and that is very
important for his life let me tell you
that so the idea for a way out came to
me when me and a friend trying to find
the co-op game that wasn't just a drop
in drop out experience I wanted to play
a game where the characters had unique
personalities and goals a game where me
and a friend can embark on an emotional
journey together and this is exactly
what a way out is the game is designed
for split-screen co-op only and I mean
only so you will be able to play it
online but to get the full experience in
field we want you and your friend to
play it in your couch and gameplay-wise
yeah yeah couch tonight right action
finally yeah and what was I don't say
yeah let me tell you ok wait it's coming
to me
and ah come on gameplay wise is going to
be crazy it's going to be huge amount of
variation it's going to be able to play
everything I mean not everything but a
lot of stuffs they're going to be
exploration driving action also you want
to get tired this game I'm telling you
so but let me tell you this after you
finish playing a way out I will tell you
you will play a co-op game like never
before I know I I mean I can guarantee
that I know I sound very cocky but I
can't help but because it's true I'm so
pumped up it's crazy you don't know I
live breathe this game I'm telling you
it's like
it's going to kick ass is going to kick
ass so right now I will show you a
gameplay video it's going to show you
just a small part of the game but still
you're going to get blown away and I
also want to say that I'm so proud and
happy to be part of this industry it's
crazy how fun it is to be here and do
these games it's so much fun and also
one last thing one last thing I want to
say hello to my Haslett team watching
live from Sweden thank you goodbye hug
shaky boom come on our way out is a
story-driven co-op game
it is designed played and experienced
only in split-screen co-op which means
you have to play the game with a friend
or about either online or on your couch
the game starts in a prison you play as
Vincent L do unit friend will get to
know your characters and unfold their
story together anything about me man
maybe not but Harvey kills someone very
close to me
with or without you I'm going after let
me show you some of the scenarios in the
game on the right side you see Li you
was already in prison on the left you
see Vincent who just arrived now if you
look to the right again you can see that
Leo can be controlled while Vincent is
in a cutscene here's another one
Vincent Alejo are now in the laundry
room your goal is to smuggle sheets
using a laundry cart you can approach
the scenario in different ways either
get the card with VIN oh I got a good
pack right here I think it's got your
name on it it's broken I don't know or
with Leo
get over here you idiot yeah but I think
those two guys are just about to fight
ah what's up what was it
and a way out you will experience
something new all the time everything
you do in the game is unique for that
scene we want you and your friend to be
focused and engaged throughout the
entire story but let me tell you this is
just the beginning of what you will be
experiencing in a way
[Music]
get it
relax ma'am I got this
I know I know me again
Thank You Joseph that game is absolutely
stunning and I can't wait for you guys
to get your hands on it
now let's switch gears for just a minute
it's great to be here showing you the
games you'll play this year but at the
same time we are inspired to look
farther ahead creative ideas combined
with new technologies become an
unstoppable force we have teams today
taking technologies that are changing in
the world and using them to change the
way we play these are the Futurists the
incubators are talented artists
designers and engineers within our
Studios our frost biting our digital
platform team and a new research
division called seed what motivates me
every day is responsibility we have to
push our industry forward that's one
reason we created this new division seed
is a small stealthy team that I work
with on a daily basis exploring some of
our most visionary concepts like deep
learning or neural networks creating a
world for you to define to interact with
and share as you wish or virtual virtual
humans with deeply sophisticated
artificial intelligence so instead of
one main character shared by millions we
can have millions of main characters
shaped by you that's just the beginning
of how we can blur reality and the
digital world go anywhere share your
discoveries be anyone the games become
yours now what we know today is that
interactive entertainment will change
more in the next five years than it has
in the last 45 together we are building
that future one that disrupt empowers
and is full of play and to do that we
also need innovative new platform
technology so when we were thrilled when
we got our first project
Scorpio dev kits from Microsoft six
teraflop stand true 4k graphical
fidelity
now these Matt and elephant FL 18
visuals are just a taste of what can be
accomplished combining frostbite with
project Scorpio and already we are
creating the most detailed
high-resolution environments you've ever
seen on a console Madden looks
absolutely stunning but as game makers
awesome graphics and effects are just
the beginning the game has to feel
amazing as well Trotta Scorpio is a
powerful platform it is coming at the
right time now I have one more thing
before I go new IP is one of the purest
forms of innovation in our industry a
brand new idea combined with the latest
tech and a vision for something
extraordinary the next game will push
every boundary for you it is vast
dangerous beautiful and unexpected so
this is just the first T's that we're
showing you today then we will have so
much more in the Microsoft press
conference tomorrow so don't miss that
but for now here's the first glimpse of
our brand new IP from Bioware
[Music]
the wall it's our armor it protects us
from what lies beyond
but out there you either live with the
choices you make
or die trying to change them
[Music]
the story doesn't end here it's just the
beginning
hey everybody I'm Sean O'Brien and I'm
here today to share the latest about NBA
Live 18 with you but instead of talking
about it I'd like to show you we've
spent the last two years completely
overhauling virtually every aspect of
gameplay now we're going to go outside
to a hands-on stationed out in Fan Fest
so you can check out some of those
improvements and then we're going to
come back in here give you more details
about how NBA Live 18 introduces an
entirely new way to play a basketball
game we call it the one Gibbs Connor
over to you
Thank You Sean you look fantastic every
single time I see you we are here out at
fan fest EA play I want to see everyone
on social use that hashtag EA played
something what games you're excited to
see I am telling you right now
I am excited to see a first look at NBA
Live 18 and no one better in the
business that my guy right here creative
director Conor Dugan Conor let's take
first look MBA live 18 yeah what's up I
mean I'm super excited that people
finally get to get their hands on NBA
live we're gonna take a look at a replay
we just got cue and I we're playing I'm
controlling Leblanc LeBron Q's
controlling KD let's take a look get all
these angles in here wanna see sweat
alright so what we're looking at here is
I'm using my right stick dribble control
I'm preparing any combination of moves I
want I can go behind the back between
the legs and now I'm trying to attack
the basket but KD or q cuts me off with
it like a big left stick and then I try
to go back at him again this time I'm
gonna go middle but huge late he doesn't
hit his left stick he misses a timing
window and now I have an open lane to
the hoop so we see Zaza coming over tell
me he finishes strong he got on strong I
use my right stick to finish with the
left hand as you can see here right over
top is aza
we have it
[Music]
last door on baby that's what it's all
about right there I appreciate this
first look at NBA Live 18 Sean back to
you thanks fellows thank you we're
excited for all of you to get your hands
on NBA Live 18 and everyone will have an
opportunity to do so through a free demo
coming in August now this demo will give
everyone the chance to start the one and
be introduced to this new basketball
world jumpstart your own legacy through
solo co-op and multiplayer experiences
and carry all of your progress over to
the full game now let's take a look at
the one NBA Live 18 as an all new way to
pursue your legacy sent it on you your
journey is defined by the choices you
make welcome to the one the one
unleashes the freedom to play how and
with whom you want here the respect you
weren't on the streets matters just as
much as the rings you earn in the league
rise through the ranks in the league an
authentic NBA experience where you
dominate the hardwood on your way to
winning championships but the new NBA
LIVE goes beyond the league taking you
into the streets with the rules and how
you weren't respect our different team
up with friends to take down NBA legends
at historic courts like Venice Beach
throughout your journey your encore
performance leads to increased skills
and new gear as your height builds in
both the streets and the lead from
Venice to Rucker Park and everywhere in
between join the community with five on
five pick up games at iconic real world
courts hit the drew league and continue
to build your legacy in the program tour
earn the right to go head-to-head with
the very best and show off your
signature style from East Coast to West
Coast from the streets to the league
everything you do matters your legacy is
defined by you
you choose to play this is your world
it's time for you to be the one
I got nothing
[Music]
what
I got trouble so much
I just win again they win they get like
Wimbledon they serve yeah they're still
like in the Zelda engine in this legging
where you see fireworks in coffee I know
how you switch em thanks guys
and thanks to all the teams here sharing
games today and a special things to
Joseph and Hayes light how about that
for some passion now we've got a massive
finale coming up here in just a moment
thirty minutes of pure unadulterated
Star Wars but but before we get there I
wanted to pause for just a moment
last week we did something pretty
amazing together we held our annual EA
play to give campaign celebrating the
importance of inclusion and play in our
communities and in life we've partnered
with three outstanding charities the
United Nations he for she and
anti-bullying organizations the pacer
Center and ditch the label we not okay
we donated a million dollars these three
great organizations in support of
building a more inclusive world and
here's where play comes in all of you
are millions of players out there joined
us in support of inclusion you came out
in play in nine in game challenges and
by coming together we are showing the
world what a positive force that games
can be and to thank you for that
we're opening ways for you to play a
bunch of great games for free start your
day for the rest of the week origin
access as well as the vault in EA access
are free for PlayStation 4 players will
also have a bunch of free trials running
all week we're talking FIFA Madden PVC
garden warfare 2 Star Wars Battlefront
and much more so jump in bring your
friends have fun with some great games
this week while you're getting ready and
excited for what's to come now without
further ado we bring you Star Wars
Battlefront 2
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello I'm Janina gavankar and I play
commander iDEN versio leader of the
Inferno squad in Star Wars Battlefront 2
I'm also an advocate for in-depth cinema
caliber story in games that tweet from
John boyega was like the tweet heard
around the world it spoke for all of us
when we watch them an untold story a
story that delivers new perspectives and
enables us to play as some of our
favorite Star Wars characters while also
introducing new ones and just like rogue
one tells an essential Star Wars story
ahead of a new hope Star Wars
Battlefront 2 will tell a new Star Wars
story that helps bridge the gap between
Return of the Jedi and the force awakens
it's good but EA didn't just stop there
we loved the previous battlefront of
2015 but we wanted more Star Wars
Battlefront 2 is much bigger than the
previous title with more than three
times the content of the first game
now I'm all about that couch co-op and
they're bringing it back with the return
of skirmish so I'm going to be cuddling
up with someone playing me some
battlefront - in multiplayer there are
more heroes more vehicles more planets
I've been to some of them more space
battles in Starfighter assault and
deeper progression and customization as
well as content from across all eras but
as we know Star Wars is not just some
checklist of great features
how does battlefront to play the team at
Dyson Stockholm has some of the most
talented multiplayer designers in the
world and they've been working with the
EA game changers to make sure Star Wars
Battlefront 2 has the multiplayer we're
all looking for these game changers they
basically get like tapped on the
shoulder because the best battlefront
players in the world and then it gets
secretly flown out to Stockholm as long
as they provide valuable feedback they
get an early look at the game it sounds
like an awesome program and if I didn't
suck at multiplayer maybe I get an
invite that's true
so let's hear more from them about their
time at dice after the release of Star
Wars Battlefront 1 the community thought
there should have been more and the good
news is this the developers have been
listening
I'm really excited to let the
game-changers get their hands on the
game this is going to stay right sorry
the clean UI look is going to stay
there's still time to change something
if it's not working
[Music]
oh my god my first impression with the
game is upgraded all three eras are
gonna be in the game got a whole bunch
of new features one of the biggest ones
that a lot of fans are excited about is
the class system they split the
characters up into different classes
they have different weapons special
abilities that you can customize it
affects your health it affects how you
are gonna support your team there's
gonna be more content you're gonna have
to get used to a lot of new different
techniques on how to play the gunplay
and the weapons have completely been
redone compared to the first battlefront
now there is a length and skill gap in
it feels a lot better and go okay this
gun feels kind of more real less
floating which is your favorite arrow so
far we're introducing a system called
battle points which will allow you to
become not only heroes but other things
on the battlefield as you're helping
your team play the objective you gain
these points there's such a plethora of
things to spend it on vehicles or even
coming in as a hero and the coolest
thing I think is a level customization
not just from a weapons standpoint but
the actual characters own abilities
collaborating with the game-changers is
always a really great working
environment when you're trying to figure
things out
I mean to know that you're giving give
feedback to make it a better experience
for everybody
it's like putting your footprint out
there and saying look I'm part of this
you're on a position yeah already so I'm
going to participate in making the
trailer it's a whole different level of
fantasy 3 2 and now on behalf of the EA
game changers and dice this is the world
premiere of Star Wars Battlefront 2
multiplayer gameplay
[Applause]
[Music]
sector is clear
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh wait Star Destroyer but we need to
clear that escort it's giving everything
we got
your next assignments they are unusual
trying
Yoda Darth Maul wookies kylo Ren vs. Ray
I watched that thing like 20 times
backstage with my mom before this even
started my mom's here yes it's a big day
for me I'm sorry so okay so we have even
more exciting things for you in just a
moment you two personality iJustine
shoutcaster Alex Golden Boy Mendes and
dice developer Paul Koechlin will
showcase a salt on feed the world
premiere of Star Wars Battlefront 2's
multiplayer yep we've got 39 game
changers ready to go head-to-head in a
twenty versus twenty match babylon feed
and i'm going to take the 40th slot
listen okay but you're not gonna want to
miss this because like maybe you've seen
some teasers but this is the real thing
okay all the bells and whistles all the
newness but before we take you there
another big Star Wars Battlefront fan
has some exciting news hi guys it's John
boyega here
thought I wasn't gonna turn up yes I was
but I'm sorry I can't be there with you
because I'm doing a play in London but I
do have some great news obviously you
know I'm a massive fan of Star Wars
Battlefront 1 and now we're going into
the next chapter with Star Wars
Battlefront 2 and I'm very very excited
to share this news with you we've seen
Yoda we seen Luke we've seen all the
other characters but where's Finn Finn
will definitely be a part of Star Wars
Battlefront 2 alongside with Captain
phasma as part of the first season of
free content and there's more on top of
that we also get to play on the new
planet crate that you saw at on the last
Jedi teaser trailer in April so this is
going to be an exciting time I'm gonna
be playing if you see Finn running
around whooping some ass it's me so I'm
getting ready getting set for you guys
to play with me on Star Wars Battlefront
2 and I'm excited let's play
okay but did you listen pinin phasma are
headed to Star Wars Battlefront to this
holiday and it will be free yes
the team at dice heard our feedback loud
and clear on the previous battlefront
and are committed to keeping this
community together with themed seasons
of content post launch for all players
at no additional charge
so the first season inspired by Star
Wars the last Jedi is only the beginning
of the additional content coming to this
game all post-launch heroes maps weapons
and vehicles will be free for everyone
who owns Star Wars Battlefront - yes and
yesterday EA announced that players who
pre-order will get early access to
multiplayer beta and Yoda's epic
lightsaber mastery star card so let us
recap new essential Star Wars story
multiplayer across all three Star Wars
eras space battles split-screen co-op
and free content that will keep us
playing together for years to come
yes right yes
yes I am so honored to be a tiny little
part of this team making this amazing
game I can't believe they let me do this
today and I can't wait to play the game
in its entirety in November and I get to
start right now so I'm going to go pick
up my controller and I'm going to throw
it over to iJustine and Golden Boy and
Paul to take us to assault on Theed
the world premiere of Star Wars
Battlefront two's multiplayer
thanks so much hey guys welcome to the
world premiere of Star Wars Battlefront
two's multiplayer gameplay assault on
Theed we're ready to show you guys the
live gameplay for the first time I'm
your host
iJustine and with me here today we've
got Golden Boy and Palk esslyn producer
from DICE what have we got going on here
today guys we got a lot going on today
first of all what we're going to see
today is a three stage mode it's our new
gameplay will be showing the we'll be
showing people going are the joys are
attacking feed they'll be going all the
way up the main the main pathway towards
the Royal Palace they need to escort the
MTT tank from there if we progress the
stage to the droids need to try to
bypass security make their way into the
palace itself if they're successful
they'll be able to take on the throne
room and they're the droids will ideally
try to capture that from the Clone Army
unfortunately the Clone Army still there
needs to try to push them out and make
that last in we should take a moment
here and preciate the fact that we get
to beat droids in Star Wars this is
gonna be awesome
I can't where you guys excited man you
guys got to come alive over here because
we're gonna see some great gameplay we
have some great great game changers who
are gonna be competing here and I use
competing as a term because these guys
are holding nothing back Jesse yeah I
know it's been super exciting and we got
a chance to play yesterday and it's just
really fun to sort of get into this
environment you know it's something that
we've seen in the movies we're actually
in the gameplay and with somebody here
who has actually worked on the game so
let's talk more about what we're seeing
here and getting into this cuz there's
three phases to this so currently we're
in phase 1
that's right and also we have some great
game changers so one of them pop up just
a little while I was a VF updates pool
shark moose elk we also have my boy
darkness AKA dankness he will be playing
as well we have a wet feet masterji Star
Wars HQ and some NBA LIVE just cut why
not you know Stuart thanks anyway here
you go
so Star Wars Battlefront 2 folks now
this is awesome because essentially
phase 1 you get to ask for an instant
team down the street of beat here and
the pressure is on for the clones you
have to hold back the assault here they
do definitely the the joys are sit there
trying to escort that MTT up the main
pathway if they're if they're successful
we go on to that phase 2 but right now
we're seeing some time some specials
gameplay from my big battle from updates
yeah let's actually talk about the
specialist and also you're gonna see a
couple of different classes here this
class in particular the massive geez
using is the heavy class specialist
tinier sniper rifle exactly about what
did they do so the heavy class is great
they got a bit more health in your
average trooper they're also able to pop
that combat shield try to push into area
so you can see those guys pushers or
defenders in some areas but looks like
we got one of our vulture droids right
now not sure who's flying this guy but
these guys are great at air-to-air
trying to take out those other ships
that might be coming in the who n1
Starfighter otherwise you're there to
provide some great ground support like
we're seeing here trying to get some
strafing runs in on those groans oh come
on man yes that's our you just you just
did it wrong there buddy sorry but we
also do have the air support but we also
have ground support as well
do we do so another thing that those air
vehicles are great at is trying to take
out some of the the ground vehicles that
you may see the droid army has the AAT
tank something that's really great at
troop suppression although we see here a
little clip of the V Wing doing that oh
man he's just mowing some some droids
down there
yeah just absolutely shredding you're
gonna see this happen quite a bit
especially in this phase because there's
a lot of open fields here right and you
just come through for some great
straight great bombing runs really and
eliminate as many people as possible
Canon also you put the presence of an
air vehicle out there players will fear
the skies and they will you know look
for cover in this map where it's already
difficult to find cover to begin with in
the phases absolutely and you can see
right now that there is an AAT tank
sitting around on the battlefield he has
probably taken out those phone troopers
but this this droid this vulture droids
really stepping it up what I love about
this is everyone's like oh look at this
great open map and then when you start
phase two is like everything starts
coming in and coming way closer together
and we're talking a little bit more
about the assault class so for somebody
who was just started playing this never
played any previous versions do you feel
like the assault class might be for
something perfect for them to pick up I
think assault classes yes absolutely
it's something that that's painful they
so class is something that a lot of
players will be able to jump right into
there your frontline flanker attacker I
think they're gonna be fairly easy you
can get right in and just start having
your typical running gun action there's
their signature ability you see here at
the top of their screen your number two
ability that switches you over to a
shotgun you get a little bit faster and
you're able to really get in there and
kind of you know brakeless break through
those front lines I love it I love you
it is so good and it's actually when I
first used it it really caught me off
guard I wasn't expecting it that's it
wait a minute I can destroy people so I
just charged into the room and just
absolutely shredded everyone it was so
fun to play with here we also seen some
great dog toys here between the clones
and the separatist this is certainly
what a lot of folks love in Star Wars
and just really in any game that dice
makes right they just always do a good
job of the air coming he's really trying
to track him down this this vulture
oh yeah well sir can I shake him well we
got stories HQ here you know he's
playing it he's putting this all class
again and you saw him he has the
signature thermal detonator that he
he'll be able to kind of suppress some
of those guys with as he rushes in and
there are different different weapons as
well like one of the guns that I would
oftentimes use with these semi-automatic
gun it you know fired a lot slower but
you can get some great shots with it and
then there's also this nice compact SMG
style you know laughter that really
shreds through people in close range I
was you know you know I mean we want to
give me any bit variety to stuff around
you yeah also some AAT tank action here
and this is that doing what it does best
and suppressing that point trying to
keep those clones out of the way they're
trying to make their way forward as the
jelly button-- scene use a march down he
has to get away
chocolate I don't know if she try to
flank the tank that's not smart I don't
know man
maybe maybe he will maybe looks a little
combat role there gotta give you some
escape options in case you get into some
some hairy action oh we didn't get to
see this one before finally chose some
ATR T's yes so these are great for
kicking out those aat so these guys a
little quick they have an ion charge
ability that way to be able to do a
little bit more extra damage against the
tank should they see it so you can
imagine like three or four days on the
battlefield really rushing around points
like look at this you just can pick up
someone out what can you what can you
get like again what some roll if you
want okay oh I was actually gonna say
could I get shot off of it if I'm on top
of it because my body is exposed yeah
yeah that was that question was answered
you know almost immediately yeah almost
immediately oh man so mr. Moussa here
you know what for this guy to be on a
tear a little bit later as well and also
I did want to highlight we had an
officer as a matter of fact right in
front of some digging one of my favorite
classes what is it about the officer
that makes it so unique I mean my my
twitch bill is not where they used to be
I'm slower nowadays but I'm able to
really buff up my class and buff up my
teammates trying to let them get some
extra help let them push me to points
faster and what happened finally finally
some good dog fight it going in there
okay so alright Ryder what's great about
some of these starfighters is these are
accessed through our new battle point
system so instead of finding a pickup
token on the on the map like we used to
in the last game you're now able to
defend
whether you're scoring points via kills
via team play assists or you're playing
the objective like we really want
players to do you're earning points
continuously that will allow you to
spend those on whether it be a special
character whether it be a vehicle or
even a hero and the battle points did
that allows you to unlock all of those
things all those things definitely and
also something to look out for to when
we get into Phase two that's when battle
points are really gonna play a role
there right right right now definitely
you see a lot more it's an open space
you have time for this air combat is
some vehicle gameplay but once we get
inside it's gonna be a different story
that's right things are definitely to
heat up and what is this happening right
this is a lockout strongly shake him out
yep but they better enjoy their air
combat here because that's not gonna be
happening for much longer
oh man he destroy him Oh
picked off nice Johnny was I mean do any
what he need to do support his team
right it's that combined arms fire you
want to make sure that somebody's trying
to cover you from the air oh boy so and
you can see after every respawned as
well you get those how many points you
earn that's right users later on got
some specialist gameplay here as well
maybe you can take off a couple faces
perhaps I'm still in the specialist
class you can also deploy different
types of traps yeah absolutely so they
have access to a trip on so if you want
to sit there if you want to be you know
that true sniper character you set up
some trip mines behind yourself make
sure nobody can flank you
to provide some tight cover fire your
shoes downrange and it's especially in
hopes in this area because it is such a
big open area so that's special some
really shining faith one
more bombing runs here and just
absolutely tearing them up at the same
man who so gets killing it
telling it in this book yet again he's
doing great oh let me see there uh one
of the officer classes right next to one
of the clothes officers fantastic for
pushing right you want to be able to
push the objective definitely support
your team like if you are playing with
your buddies you want to be able to have
at least one officer available yes he
keeps you going in the fight at least I
mean they really help push you know when
those heavies are trying to drive
towards a point
you got your officers behind you giving
you some extra help making sure that
you're not you're still able to complete
that push or on the opposite side if
you're one of the droids you really need
to lock down a point the officers have
access to a turret that they can place
on the ground and you know give it a
little bit more fire support for that
area trying to see massive G here's a
you know he's really focused on the
bombing drugs right he's not trying to
go into combat with Musa who's up there
there's a darkness forty nine just
shredding everyone up here maybe I don't
get a compliment we just went to the
beach mode yeah this is happening oh yes
so tell us about the siege mode versus
how's this play out in siege mode for a
limited time you're able to just blow up
some huge area effect shots you lock
down your position but you're able to
have a lot more firepower we also just
saw the b2 super battle droid there as
well that's something
another Wi-Fi flavor as well another one
of my favorites uh yeah you can grab
those guys we have the battle point
system those guys great at pushes once
again where they have high health a lot
of rapid fire oh here we go there it is
and this big explosion indicates phase
one is over now we start phase two and
this is when the action really begins to
pick up here because it gets really
tight inside of that building and
players need to be mindful of that and
look for this b2 to just shred through
everyone especially with that cooling
ability that
as to be able to keep him just
constantly shooting in the fight he's
gonna he's gonna make a huge difference
he has a five minutes inside I mean
there's gonna be narrow pathways he's
gonna be able to just shred as soon as
anybody gets in his way
because its nose nor those narrow
corridors could be trouble and just
waiting for the prime opportunity to
push up here players falling got now you
know why Foy they're they're all here we
go this is some normal action here we go
folks doors which starts to get
interesting
this would get scary Darth Maul will
excel in phase 2 and phase 3 Ezra inside
I mean he's a great mobile attacker he's
gonna sit there with his eyes through
those quarters - oh absolutely I mean
some of this ability as you can see here
he's got that squid attack he's able to
who just rush in and out of combat and
just take eyes out the process was funny
I was talking to himself earlier and he
was using dark small and he was saying
how there's Boba Fett as well I mean he
was talking about how he wishes Darth
Maul could reflect it was like if he
could reflection oh that was a good
flank by public fetch ball just shredded
the clone army unfortunately what role
does double Fett fill of his battle Boba
Fett is definitely a hunter-killer
so if the other if the Clone Army is
able to get some of their heroes in play
like this is where Boba Fett was really
shining with that jetpack in his he's
able to kind of float above the
battlefield fire off some rockets and
really just take out an individual
target it's a good difference to see up
in the last game uh the last game would
give him a bit new tricks he's got a new
concussion rocket the only disorient
players completely
it has rocket barrage instead of just
one rocket he's able to drill a nice
nice also one thing to keep in mind we
saw the b2 here we go but on the clone
side you know there are specialists in
characters that you can pick up as well
we haven't seen much of it yet but that
would be the clone jump shoot birth
that's right very different from the
standard like ass all class of heavy
class it has the jump Jets that you love
from battlefront the original that's
right brought back here but now focus on
the central class exactly yeah back to
mobile bed here with good look at that
he's shredding able just laid out so
much firepower content oh they got him
no down jesse was able to find him on
that one
but here comes some officer gameplay
here oh good finally somebody placing
support supporting people matter
did you know he kind of give him some
we're the linchpin of the team you know
yeah exactly now what is this - exactly
is - stealing these two buildings at
yeah exactly it's that healing ability
gives you a little bit of buff for your
a little over health but it also heals
you back up so it's oh here we got some
of the the jump troopers oh boy and here
we go it's ready for Phase three in just
a little bit there's a jump true but we
talked about them before
jump shooters super fun to play but
again you know it's attached to a
specialist now so now everyone's gonna
have any clip although it was really fun
in the original battles right but I'm
gonna be excited that hopping to jump
tree brings read people
I mean I know people we love this people
love people love to jump at om you've
got ray oh well I I'm super excited to
play as Harry achieved she's a quite a
powerful character for us I'm sure you
know she got out of that one really
don't run quickly but oh they got
destroyed fallen by a finish the roid
sing no beret hasn't survived
hello activities absolutely so raise
mind trick is something against all
enemies you'll be confused for a little
bit your controls were kind of no work
against you making you a little bit more
vulnerable to attack just so you guys
know this is when it gets anything
because they there's so much going on
here and old with that we saw a little
Han yeah we're gonna get some hot I hope
so but I mean you saw it early so every
time you finish a life will show you how
many battle points you have it some
people have enough points get those
reinforcements especially this late in
the game you'll see a lot more these
special classes coming out a lot more
the heroes coming out so again his jump
to three here you know with his rocket
launcher in a jump act trying to be
mobile trying to fly into that that last
zone and capture point this is really
where heavies are gonna thrive as well
and there is you laying down fire the
doorway just absolutely dominating
clones they need to put down they need
the fight this went out here there are
so many lives left that the separatists
have to their team they could really run
through this two phones have to start
acting fast because if they cap it that
will be it the separatists will win this
game it's not looking so good for my
boys in the car me I'm a separatist man
so I'm excited I'm just gonna go on
whichever team wins oh I'm not gonna
beat you thinking here jumpin ship I
understand that you know no loyalties
maybe you are sick maybe I am oh that's
fine yeah so in the third page though in
the droids are trying to capture that
throne room so you can see here if you
remember it's just this is the main this
is the main throne and this is such
super close quarters do you have any
legs for the strategies that you would
add absolutely I'm just missing if
you're the cones you're hoping that oh
geez I'm sold she's getting torn up
that's gonna be trouble
it's like too soon man I can relive
force awakens again you know like don't
do it don't fall is just destroying
absolutely everything is there any tips
to like taking him down I mean you want
to have a try to combined arms fire ah
the tip is blasters run away maybe run
away run away shoot the crap out of
Darth Maul oh man he was our MVP look at
that nice boots out congratulating 36
kills he ended up thinking is my
goodness well guys that was it what did
you guys think the tents not bad
actually
nah I'm line freakin awesome I love it
it's so good it's like I love the class
based gameplay personally because again
you can really get your squad your
friends to get together and say like hey
I want to you know run the officer and
where you can run to do some highlights
here maybe not listen that's not the
best uh you know because although maybe
it was
oh please just a crash montage I think
that's what we're gonna do at this point
all crashing all the time I'm down with
that but it was new suck I mean you said
there's no getting as many battle points
as he can before his next life I mean
that's what you want to try to see you
this battle system you want to either
snowball your points keep earning them
keep earning them keep building getting
more for more things yeah that's great
and again you know just the game one
thing I do want to compliment and you
know a nice just the way the game it's
it's so beautiful
especially seeing this part of the Star
Wars universe brought to life the way
that they with you guys really managed
to do something kudos on that one once
again you know just drop dropping jaws
everywhere we'll try you try I mean the
team back home is amazing they do
incredible things and you can see it
looks so pretty but just look at this
this laser fires too tense and it looks
beautiful it really does look incredible
so yeah are we discussing right now you
know like we get into game looks good
but that was awesome I and overall I
mean you don't have to say like I can't
wait to get my hands on it I can't wait
to coordinate with my friends you know
and destroy the clone scum
I can't let hurt yes you know exactly
separatist all day well guys that was so
awesome now if you guys are in LA you
can come join us at fan fest this
weekend and if you come down on Monday
we've got a chance for you guys to win a
trip to Gamescom in Germany this August
all you have to do is come and play
which is I mean that's not asking too
much and you have to be the best player
of your match you guys will be entered
to win a trip for two to Cologne Germany
and a full ps2 games gone before yeah
I've been there plenty times it's one of
the most ridiculous conventions ever if
you happen to go it's insane its massive
so you're not you're if you don't get
the trip you're gonna be really sad but
if you do get the trip you and buddy oh
you're gonna have a good time it's a fun
time hopefully I'll see you there well
if you guys like Star Wars like we do
and you guys want to play as your
favorite heroes and villains you guys
can download Star Wars Galaxies of
heroes right now on Android or iOS and
you can play as any of the iconic
characters did you guys saw today and
many more pulp I also heard that you're
making a battlefront too because you've
been playing a lot a lot of a galaxy of
euros I play a ton of galaxy sorry to
cut that short but I don't think we're
missing too much welcome back everybody
to game spots III stage we just saw a
EA's press conference a couple new games
couple things we did not expect couple
things we did expect we want to get into
it the next half hour after that be able
to keep playing a few games I believe
they're playing Madden later maybe FIFA
and Battlefield one DLC but first I want
to bring it back to our crew to talk
about what we just saw Peter Brown huh
we just saw battlefield one DLC in the
name of the Czar yeah and we had talked
about how it might be bring it to the
Russian front and now we know for sure
that it is we also know that it's
bringing two night maps which would be
pretty cool into the multiplayer that's
nice yeah
it's bringing the what is the like the
battalion of death the women's battalion
of death from the Russian army I don't
know much about that historically but it
sounds pretty badass I'm curious to see
how this will bring people back into the
game I'm here with Kelly plaguey and Rob
hammering
both of which you played battlefield 1 a
decent amount Robby especially solution
is what do you think of this Russian yes
solution it was just a little teaser
like people have to uh yeah I again
later on they're gonna show some more
gameplay but we that will officially
sell me but yeah this is these are see
new vehicles
yeah I would train I mentioned yeah yeah
wow that could be he miss presumably
right right so it is these from fun
and yeah this looks pretty pretty cool
as far as like yeah you know first snow
map looks like you can impale someone
while on horseback I guess that seems
new to me you'd also talked about how
you wanted how the weather dynamic
weather effect it does look like
blizzard will be playing into it the
cold somehow um I'm hoping it's not just
another sandstorm like that you've
already used in the desert maps and
hoping maybe it actually plays into
something there's some sort of different
element to cold my effect it I don't
know I'll be super cool up vehicles or
something yeah maybe like slows you down
yeah there's movement um and then I'm
curious about like these maps there's
two new night maps which can change how
you play obviously like lower visibility
just like we talked about sandstorms but
the actual Eastern Front um huge like a
lot of people fought in it or World War
one on curious how like there's eight
new total maps right here it's like if
those two night maps are included in
that eight or if those are separate
think they are but I think the vel
Knights believe that is the
franco-german franco-british versus
Germans I think that was actually in
France okay so they're doing Eastern in
I guess new French Maps well you guys
things will be enough to bring you back
in the game this summer could possibly I
was you know they didn't talk much about
like you know earlier the pre-show we
had we were talking about you know what
we wanted they said yeah there him
friends and how that would work out any
changes I was hoping for that but
hopefully maybe they touch on that in
the later gameplay yeah yay play they're
doing mm-hmm yeah I didn't actually play
too much battlefield one so I think this
is going to be the reason for me to to
really get back into it I'm really I
mean like I like I said before I'm
really excited about the the Russian
women's battalion which is just super
cool like a historically very
interesting to me and just having a
reason with all the great games that we
have out now like having a reason to
revisit one from last year that I kind
of didn't have a chance like a great
game from last year so yeah I mean DLC
is always a good reason to get back into
something if it's good you know okay if
it's not good then no no yeah we saw a
decent mount of the in the name of the
Czar DLC but we also saw a ton of
battlefront too which I want to get into
later but I do want
a couple things we saw earlier the show
we saw a continuation of Alex hunters
story if you played FIFA 17 that was the
the journey mode where it actually
followed a character through cutscenes
and look dude you know trial in his
career and his actual journey through I
believe the Premier League but they also
showed in the this Donal why he's kind
of like Game Boy said suck Cristiano
Ronaldo's motion capture it goes back to
Alex hunter and appears he is here in LA
actually playing for the Los Angeles
Galaxy in Major League Soccer the whole
question of everybody like in the news
cover saying I'm gonna stay over in
Europe or is he gonna come over here you
know a lot gave it back up in front of
Los Angeles Galaxy
um and I'm curious you know it looks
like NBA Live is also kind of following
it you might be predicted in FIFA's
footsteps with a character in a story
given mode but it also sounds like
they're kind of you know like putting a
lot of emphasis on the crowds the
atmospheres they kept saying the actual
arena is here they start showing the
crowds a lot saying it's gonna feel more
like a dynamic crowd and I'm curious if
that'll actually really affect 20 the
game all that okay no I won't affect
playing the game at all I mean it's to
affect your perception of the thing
you're looking at I mean that's always
gonna win a FIFA's classic problem this
is that you know problems at least in
the eyes of people that are the most
passionate about it is that they don't
really care so much about these cosmetic
upgrades that's not really the point
that's not why they play a game like
FIFA maybe then that is why they play a
game like Pro Evolution Soccer instead
so I mean good to see that they're still
improving that I guess but that's not
the really good thing to focus on mhm
yeah like we because I just mentioned
NBA Live is also doing a similar thing
with the one mode sounds kind of it's
like the year of story mode in sports
game yeah well Madden has the the long
shot I believe they said which is more
of an aging player trying to come back
into the game but yeah it seems like
they're following in battlefront twos
footsteps of bringing a single player
story into it I mean they would not
expect of sports games but as someone
who used to play Madden yearly up until
maybe 2010 or something then stopped and
FIFA a lot would like my siblings it's
actually kind of cool and I I don't I
didn't play fifa 17 so I don't know how
well it worked
I know Oscar Danis not UX UK office
plays it a ton but I know like him and a
lot of people had gripes with in my new
show
sefa 17 but with the journey to and like
all these minor things that they're kind
of tweaking and what Madden especially
they're trying to say like met and 17
they're putting a lot of emphasis on the
actual moment a moment like juking and
running and the actual passing gameplay
but these story modes are kind of the
most interesting part to me maybe as
someone from the outside looking in at
these EA Sports it's it seems like the
one thing with like these games right
that Peter you mentioned like before
there's not much you would want to
change you don't want to steer too far
off that track so it's like a story mode
of where you can take more of your risks
and to also excite someone coming in to
have something different to play I yeah
I mean especially with NBA Live we saw a
lot of really nuanced control like the
control scheme seemed really really
in-depth um so it was cool for like the
really hardcore player but I like that
for somebody who's maybe dropped off
from these games or like me who has only
ever like really watched people apply
I've never believed jumped in myself for
a lot of different sports games yeah um
the story mode is it's like it's like
they have something for both kinds of
players I like um cuz I especially like
the NBA live one is like oh you can do
the street mode or the like NBA mode
which is cool yeah they were saying they
were emphasizing like they're kind of
homegrown street playing growing up on
the streets or whatever um and then they
were actually talking about how like
that will factor into your professional
career between long shot and the won and
the journey is you can - it seems like
they're all taking that approach one
thing I do wanna mention with FIFA we
know it's coming to the switch right we
didn't really see anything do you think
that something will see with Nintendo's
conference if is it big enough to
warrant attention I'd be shocked no I
don't think we're gonna see it from
antennas conference yeah I feel like
that well I mean if we do maybe like a
five second clip yeah like that they're
not working with a lot of time this year
sure so and I don't I mean I don't think
that's the preferred platform for a lot
of people playing Fifa right they're
just gravitate toward you know
Playstation or Xbox yeah
and then of course we did see much more
of a need for speed payback which we
talked about before in the pre-show but
and we kind of said you know they're
going for this um what do you want say
fast and furious vibe more like heists
and whatnot and actual kind of action
and we saw this chase they were taking
out a truck there
our three playable characters and it
seemed to switch between them Robbie
you're saying he thought it might be one
that you picked the beginning mission
but that didn't seem to be the case
right
it seemed fairly linear like you were
helping whatever your life partner is
get on to the truck and then it Auto
switched to then your driver stealing
the car out of the truck yeah that
looked
I mean visually looks really awesome
yellow gorgeous um it was cool at the
one other thing we mentioned was like
the in that gameplay highway stretch you
you were random cars into poles and
obstacles it would cut to a slow-mo kind
of wreck cinematic that seemed to be
very much on the fly but I think you
mentioned or Peter I said was cool and
then Peters brought brought the good
point which is like let's hope you can
prevent that like I could get it could
get old right I'm gonna happen like
every 10 seconds and these clips they
were showing and I was already kind of
grown tired of it yeah hopefully you
know and that's but yeah this stuff
right here if you it be it does really
cool uh maybe yeah as long as you can
engage in disengage it I think that
especially if crashing into cars is like
a key mechanic that you can use it you
know as an offensive move if they're if
they're encouraging you to do that yeah
frankly they can be so together an
experience around kind of like a sped up
motive a member when I first saw like
doom gameplay I was worried that the
what were those attacks called the me
little Rico lorry kills was like palta
momentum but if they could get but right
here it looks like it actually is
helping like them also this truck
destroyed like half of a city yeah yeah
they're definitely the banter between
the three characters it sounds like one
has a foreign accent of some sort just
assuming it's like an international
group of fuse or something it definitely
gave me like almost you know like vessel
fairies being the obvious comparison but
like an Ocean's eleven vibe to kind of
adjust like this dump
between people Alex doing some heist
family job ya know I'm curious to see
how this would have to fire up a story
it also looks like they are ditching the
live-action cutscenes unless they just
have yet to show us I think they're not
gonna do it I think they're the smart
react young everything was a backlash it
was just like what I'm just glad enough
pursuing it again yeah yeah because it
was kind of crazy to us okay I only saw
it yeah I need for ski to pay back yeah
there's a lot of customization of cars
they were pushing for they're talking
about in the press conference which kind
of feeds into what you were talking
about for the horizon yeah I remind me I
forget what system was enforced but you
would you know you find those cars and
restrained it out in the world and then
you you were calling them in if I'm in
like Barnes or yeah Barnes I thank our
minds
you just find my car no no there was
something more fights
barn fights share our fights oh Jesus
but that seemed neat and then you know
you could probably cater it like again
they were really emphasizing the
customization option yes right so you
can take these classic cars like a bug
it looked like was one of them and
really like you know customize it but
like a cool grill on it and lift it need
some underglow yeah uh yeah but it also
saw I think one of the more surprising
things of the show we talked about you
know the fact that Yosef Forest was
coming onto to e3 this year and after
they announced that they were gonna yeah
I was gonna support his last game this
game after brothers tell two stones was
published by star breeze and now they
are he came on stage to show off a way
out
which looks like a cross between
Shawshank Redemption and like uncharted
and break watch Prison Break
so that first teaser trailer back in
2014 I think was just them on or one or
two characters on that the cargo on the
char of a train right and now this has
to be played coops put screen right
where the first game could not play cuz
I would have ruin the experience play
online
he also said online yeah okay sorry the
online themes that seems not the right
director very difficult oh right if
you're if you were required to have
another player online and someone drops
like I don't know just it's a huge
barrier yeah like if it's a ran
person said I don't have any friends to
play with then I want to get into this
game
I am hair it up with someone who is
questionable right like as far as like
their interconnection and then I'm
getting dropped and then what happens
then someone just man sure swap in I
don't know these are bail concerns but I
think you know we have to at least close
to strive for best-case scenarios like
you know it's in order to like have
experimental projects like this yeah
yeah others was yeah totally I mean if
we if we try to keep it to the lowest
common denominator what's possible then
we're not gonna really challenge
yourself and doing the same stuff so I I
totally hear you like I these type of
things often earn me but knowing what
they do the brothers I'm willing to put
up with it to see what they can do their
next thing
yeah they talked about how one player
could be in a cutscene while the other
is just roaming around like one player
was I think in the demo one characters
in a cutscene talking about how this
character had this that could help them
out and then you see the other person
playing and going up and just like
smashing his face into the bar
you look super interesting because you
have to balance like paying attention to
the cutscene if you're the player in the
game like actual gameplay yeah we could
be vicious
yeah okay get in the closet
it has this like asynchronous element
that I think is really interesting yeah
I think it's a really smart choice to
consider like a prison break for some
like this just to have those panic
inducing moments like that I like that
one clip of them like yeah I think it's
like Shawshank Ryder like the rock for
even where they're like in the walls
like using their backs to like arch up
you know I mean like I could see or just
any chase movie they show stuff after
this where they like go back to being
criminals or you know like me it's a
good charge I mean they were before yeah
but they go once you actually break out
the game does not stop you keep doing
stuff outside it showed him you know
assaulting that police officer and then
actually kind of I think in the cutscene
planning another job of some sort and I
think they it's the prison break and
like crime element is the right setting
for this kind of co-op - because it's
like in immediately like it builds
camaraderie right away
yeah like you're gonna be like oh well
even if I don't like you I want to get
out yeah so yeah that's good point so
it's like it's it's um like uh sometimes
co-op can be hard to get into because
you're like but what is my motivation
for not just messing with whoever I'm
playing with especially if you're
playing with like you're like if I've
with my brother I'm like just gonna
screw him up yeah um this one's like
your action there's it seems like
there's actually incentive to do things
even want to play with a stranger yeah
it's in the other kind of thing yeah
absolutely yeah a way out was kind of
one of the ones that surprised me
pleasantly in a show that I don't think
surprised me all that much maybe oh just
because some of the stuff lead but we
did see anthem which is what we now know
is the new Bioware it was something IP
we saw it yeah it was pretty pretty
minimal but we know what it is called
now we know what they're going for it
definitely seems like as a destiny vibe
the wall way the wall but now there
seems like your EXO sell out Wow
exoskeletons max involved but from the
way that they were describing it before
monsters there
yeah monster somesort kind of like
locust plague or something i 5
post-apocalypse of some sort they said
we will see much more of it during
Microsoft's press conference tomorrow
which we will also be covering its
comeback for that
well yeah here you see something that
looks a bit more along the lines of like
an exosuit rather than this Bioware past
seems cool in gameplay I yeah yeah I
need to see more I'm very fatigued on
this kind of setting
yeah like I'm just like we've seen
exosuits
I've seen sci-fi post-apocalypse stuff
so much that I just not that could be
that could be minigames they showed us
yeah it's not like I haven't seen
anything that's uniquely Bioware right I
mean that's obviously a teaser like I
want to affair to it but it's the
setting is so played out that they have
to do something really surprising and
fresh with it for me to be excited
hopefully it's that story right everyone
has an extra toe that's that's the dev
seat here yeah I would play that that is
so yeah they said EA announced they
would show off more of anthem which we
now know it's called it's no longer
called Project Dylan thank God but
they'll be showing that off more at
Microsoft's press conference tomorrow
which we'll be covering and of course we
saw a ton of Star Wars Battlefront 2
nothing from respawn or visceral yeah
yeah we had hoped for as far as visceral
bozer and I had hoped for but we did see
a lot of Battlefront 2 which we knew we
would see
um went back in time to the Clone Wars
separatist for his clones in feed
capital city of Naboo like you said
earlier on the pre-show we did kind of
see we could with this happening we got
to hear narration from a few people
while this was happening so we ate a
better sense of what's going on Rob from
your time of the first game and seeing
this this new mode siege blues called it
tell me how this unfold as opposed to
what we might have seen in the first
battle for sure um it's reminiscent of
the mother last DLCs I guess you could
say the Death Star and the start from
the first game Death Star and scare off'
yeah in which there you're escorting the
Walker and the other one in this in this
case you're the separatists you're
escorting Beach transport here but then
it kind of narrows down to like phase
two which is if you know that the
separatists get through the clone lines
then it's a more close quarters take the
throne room in the building sure um nice
granny that's just the one mode they're
showing here this is all is that Gavin
they just showed that like swampy temple
planet Gavin for without of them not you
having for that would've been like like
I just showed a lot of the space battle
to the BC game playing this no I don't
think so
and I wonder like you were saying I
heard us yeah I mention a separately
load in the first element I kind of want
it to be an actual like the original
battlefront two had that you know like
the actual space battles have played out
very you know right play your focus
rabbit this separate mode yeah right and
in the last game it was just a
deathmatch yeah with no obstacles for
the most part which is boring it gets
boring after a while so you saw I mean
that's the one thing that kind of teased
was like asteroids and and flying around
that and as well as well we've sold said
is that the yo each side has a cruiser
you want to attack and share it so we'll
see some of that I guess later on I'm
about a three but sometime um but yeah
they showed off feed that that map looks
gorgeous the game will always look
gorgeous and this you noticed ethically
it's promising always I guess the most
notable thing that I took away is that
battle point system right is kind of the
enter peace opposed to the tokens that
were in the first game where if you know
battlefront you want to fly a x-wing you
got to find that token on the field and
it's random it's frustrating that goes
with the hero system as well so the
point system is basically I can you get
kills say a couple kills I can
immediately get into one of these things
there's like a viewing they said I can
choose to get into a vehicle or I can
hold out until I reach 5,000 and then I
can play Han Solo or Rey um I think
that's nice that's that's slightly a
more it's a sort of way to sort of
reward your progression and abilities
right rather than these random heroes
right just being like oh cool look at me
I stumbled on this thing I didn't
actually earn in any way shape or form
and like you might not even need like we
were seeing a lot of players picking
heroes later in the game and they were
in close quarters and so that element of
strategy 2 is stronger when you have
actual choice like you could say you
know I'll save money because I'm about
to do this final push and it would be
great to have a hero because then I'll
just power through it right first of all
strong really did power through it man
yeah yeah and that was interesting
first we saw it was we saw brain I
believe she died for sure
yeah that's wrong a hunt solo went in
shooting blindly and they are small just
tore through him as well think about
depending on who was playing yeah
totally absolutely
but Darth Maul's mobility was sure yeah
just barrel rolls I miss everybody
remember yeah in the last game it was
Emperor Palpatine yeah Errol's rated
that's what you know he basically does
that in Revenge of the Sith but Darth
Maul was a gymnast at heart like it was
very cool to see him just do those notes
and on stage that's great when it opens
up I think maybe those trailer wheezes
this is a boomerang of his lightsaber
going through like eight clone troopers
right um so that's cool yeah I think
that new system is better than what was
present before Rob is someone who likes
aerial combat in like battlefield and
first that well you wanted it does this
dogfighting seem like that it's a park
yeah I don't know it was tough that you
know they showed it within the first
five minutes to people crashing into
each other while crashing into a
building which is there's a lot of
crashing yeah so in the first game you
can walk on you hold left trigger and
you can lock on your lane
granted if you had the crosshair
centered somewhat close to their ship I
have you know you have to play it to
actually understand it you are playing
this later today right it's correct yes
yeah definitely stay tuned we'll have
gameplay and impressions uh definitely
soon I guess the other thing that was
nice is it you know when I was playing
this game more often not is you know you
you fall into that lone wolf problem of
just like I'm just gonna spawn even
though there's a partner system in the
previous battlefront you just spawn and
then you kind of do your own thing so I
mention this in the pre-show to is that
you know you now have groups of four and
now you have four different classes one
can be an officer which is more of your
overall support who drops look like the
Imperial officer had appear excuse me
clone officer had like turrets and would
provide health or steam and then upon
joining a four-person group you can
expect your I think as your battle
points your experience in the game to to
increase so you it's reinforcing the
idea of team play I think that's super
important yeah in this mode itself you
know the first game had Walker assault
but it only there were only so many ways
you could actually take down the eighty
ATS or a doubts or whatever you want to
call them but this it seems like they
were telling when they like a little
tutorial often to show them getting into
a star fighter and I was saying you
could do damage to the start to the
transport with this and then when they
got into a vehicle you could do damage
to it with this and then presumably with
those upgrades that you mentioned so you
like there's a little more flexibility
and the options you have this time
around yeah and I think the Walker self
in the previous game was just
frustrating in jail where it was like oh
the only way you can you know bring
these walkers down it is if you focus on
uplinks like I said that idea in order
bring why why why Whittington right to
stun it I think um you want to keep that
fairly simple and again I think we
reinforced like you know teamwork just
like with your squad because who wants
to go to an uplink I want to get in
there I want to shoot things I mean I
don't know yeah I still have much to
learn about all these other modes yeah
so we ain't see much of single-player
today we already wanted to see that yeah
I'm sure we'll see that in the coming
months maybe another trailer of sort
before November although I'd be fine if
they didn't reveal too much more about
it I'm already pretty excited about it
we didn't get to see too much of the
progression right between matches or at
least I would like to see more of it and
see how those RPG mechanics or RPG light
mechanics might factor into your overall
profile because I think that was one
thing the first game was lacking you
know you saw titanfall to really improve
upon the burn cards from the first game
by adding that progression that kind of
you know like I like all Duty 4 and
introduced it now every shooter used it
but I think for a good reason right it
will keep me invested in this game
longer than just the spectacle and the
actual gameplay of it might
right but I'm curious to like Callie you
said you had seen examples of a couple
months ago I showed you yeah I mean not
even seen they just basically spoke
about it when I was at Star Wars
Celebration it was it was just kind of
like oh yeah there's gonna be
progressions so you know your character
customizations will transfer from you
know era to era so like if you're
playing a this this droid trooper versus
a different era of Star Wars like your
trooper character era progression will
carry over was but I don't know the
details of that and I'm curious to see
how exactly that works and obviously we
didn't see any of that this was more of
an individual match and seeing how it
progressed progresses so um I am curious
because that is important for me to like
want to keep coming back to a shooter
Call of Duty for like you said sure yeah
and one thing that's worth mentioning is
that the DLC post release will all be
free yeah that was really big it was um
it felt like they had heard the cries of
many people like okay DLCs free now yeah
it's weird to keep talking about
titanfall so much but same thing with
titanfall right titanfall 1 the problem
they had was that it fell off kinda
quickly the player population because of
the burn cards didn't lend much to like
the launch ID the game uh you know it
released on one console as opposed to
you know - which came on a ps4 but
that's a separate thing that they
tackled but I played on 360 quite a bit
oh yeah painful Oh titanfall right what
was that yeah because there was like a
huge community on there compare that so
I'm going I would pour yeah and it's
cute it's interesting to see how they
are kind
tackling that problem with this game
because I know the numbers on
battlefront Rock weren't like dismal at
all but they weren't always great you
know like post-launch week right yeah I
think it you know again you mentioned
title to the model that I think best
suits saving is yes you make the maps
free make mostly no core weapons and
just you know cosmetics right like
that's like that's that's been almost
the standard lately is just like if you
if you want to like you know get
microtransactions out of anywhere it's
just like let it be Cosmetics yeah um or
of course you know you still have some
sort of system yeah currency in game to
progress with but yeah you got to keep
the maps open I think yeah so overall it
was a pretty pretty interesting demo I
would say I like what I saw the you know
at the siege mode that seems interesting
it seems kinda like operations in
battlefield one more kind of like
objective focus gameplay that you know
you saw but between battlefront to
Battlefield one DLC you need for speed
pay back all the EA sports games and a
way out you guys pretty impressed Callie
what do you think of this press
conference overall you think is a good
start to the week do you think is good
for ei I mean is a fine start it was
nothing that really shocked me I mean I
did like seeing a little taste of the
Bioware IP even though I wasn't
particularly impressed by it I liked
they showed that but obviously the
sports games are going to be staples so
it was pretty like what it just what
what I was expecting but I did like I
think battlefront obviously is the
strongest thing to end on and seeing
multiplayer was what I really wanted and
so yeah I mean I feel like we get a ramp
up into the week not like that wasn't a
big blowout thing or anything like that
Rober by you takeaways uh I think a way
out was the was the most impressive
thing of the conference I was a novel
thing yeah it's it seemed really
interesting like as far as yet
Battlefront as much as I am excited for
that game and I really look forward to
playing it it still look like
battlefront yeah you know like this the
systems of the replacing those tokens on
the ground I'm all for that
just you got shale plays out yes but
yeah I think a way out was the by and
large the most impressive thing yeah be
proud what about you if we're gonna talk
about the conference itself it was a
little distracting that every game had
about half of its attention focused on
these game changers as yeah uh let's
talk about the games most importantly
please um there's kind of poorly paced
conference overall I think maybe a did I
would have maybe I personally would have
rather the sports games be grouped
together because if that's what I want
to see that's what I want to see I don't
want to see it they're kind of peppered
throughout although like I said I'm
pretty interested in those story modes
at FIFA eighteen is continuing and then
be alive they could be good the better
yeah like NBA Live actually has me very
interested I think that intricate
controls were presented in sort of an
odd way because it was like staccato
like way of like letting him play in and
stopping the onion plant in stopping I'd
like to see how that actually plays out
in real time sure but as someone who
used to love playing basketball as a kid
you know the idea of rising through the
ranks but also being able to like play
on the streets and do that sort of stuff
going on quote you know is uh seems
alright she could I'm with Rob I think a
way out is definitely the most
interesting thing that we've seen so far
out of the a yeah looking at that
conference alone I'm pretty excited for
a way out
by where did peak my interest and it was
just a teaser and I am like Kelly you
had said and P you'd agreed that that
world that post-apocalyptic sci-fi
destiny kind of thing feels a little
played out at this point but I am
curious things during Microsoft tomorrow
to show much more but I am curious to
see how Bioware specifically tackles
that like we mentioned before Bioware
such a story centric like classic RPG
developer so I'm curious to see how
they're actually going to go about
taking this destiny division genre and
making it their own we will see more
that tomorrow so I'm kind of curious
about that I was like a 45 second teaser
today um but yeah overall III has
started and of course we will be
covering it here from GameSpot's
editorial stage as well as our co-op
stages downstairs we have a lot of
partners coming in throughout the week
we have kind of funny we have fun house
we have cabin sub they'll be coming to
hang out with Ches Eve Ascencio who is
going to be hosting downstairs stage we
have the lobby on Wednesday if our
weekly live show will be doing it here
for a live audience which would be
really fun it'll be asked for but we
will have Lucy James will be hosting a
ton of stuff from up here we will have
tomorrow will be Microsoft press
conference
and Bethesda which will be late at night
and then followed by Sony and Nintendo
and Who am I missing
Ubisoft later in the week and then well
of course all week have our demo stage
up right now if you want to keep
watching EA play and some of the games
we saw today the conference we're gonna
switch over to them I believe they're
playing Madden NFL 18 right now but for
now that is all from the GameSpot stage
we will see you tomorrow from Microsoft
thanks for joining us yeah it was him
and Dan Marino there the same day you've
got an NFL Hall of Famer who wants to be
a part of this and you got an Oscar
winner who want to be a part of this and
that just speaks volumes to how how it
plays on both sides of the fence first
day of shooting so I was so nervous
walking into there like it's so limited
with time when you're shooting these
things you have a half a day with
marchiali with kids so kids make it so
much more complicated because they're
just having fun and there's a football
on set and they're trying to break the
lights but just talking smack like
they'd like if it was gonna blow up it
was gonna blow up on day one yeah most
expensive well I'm glad it didn't astok
but it's for you Scott you know
obviously Friday Night Lights that's
where people will see you recognize you
from from numerous other things as well
right but what was the experience how
does it compare to what you didn't find
the lights to what you did with long
shot you know I've never worked on a
project that had as many parallels for
me to Friday Night Lights I've worked on
a bunch of other stuff but nothing had
that kind of grounded small
conversational storytelling that Friday
Night Lights had throughout the rest of
my career and so kind of it so long shot
that means to be honest with you you
know there was so much collaboration and
when I was on Friday Night Lights I felt
like I had ownership of that show
because they and powder powered us to do
this and junior said this earlier but
while doing long shot we also felt very
empowered to be a part of the
storytelling we weren't just puppets for
words that somebody was very precious
with on the page Mike had brilliant
ideas and lovely dialogue but then also
was was malleable and wanted to just we
all wanted the same thing which has had
the greatest story and that's what we
did on Friday Night Lights I would say
it's tough to catch lightning in a
bottle twice but I think that we might
have done it with this
dunno Friday Night Lights and at the
heart of Friday Night Lights it's about
interpersonal relationships about
friendships like with Jason Street and
Riggins their tragedy changes their
relationship the same thing happens with
what Devin and with Colt tragedy really
kind of changes and adjusts their
relationship and it's how they rebound
from it that is the beauty of this story
and it's how they overcome and adversity
is used way too much in sports but when
you find out what they both go through
it's true adversity it's not losing a
game it's it's losing a part of your
life and how they join together and
forge their friendship going forward and
and and push each other to try and
achieve the biggest accomplishment they
ever could heading towards the NFL Draft
it's just a wonderful beautiful story
and storytelling starts at just like
Friday Night Lights long shot does the
same thing and I think that's we duck
you asked the question about how it's
relatable I think that's what it is it's
not really it's not just a story about
football it's a story that all of us has
been through in some capacity yeah
trying to overcome with people that we
love and trying to you know jump over
obstacles it's the human story right I
mean it's laughter we're all trying to
accomplish different things to
accomplish different goals how do we get
there they have and flow of all that in
I mean that's what I'm taking from what
you're saying but okay are we willing
are we willing when we're most down are
we willing to look in the mirror and
face that and do something about it
essentially I mean in the trailer you
have that moment where Devin's you know
walking towards the window looking at
Lucas Oil you know are you are we gonna
are we gonna be strong enough to
actually get up off the couch look in
the mirror and take action I'll be
honest jr. when you watching yourself in
that scene are you looking at Lucas Oil
are you just are you just looking at
your reflection in the hotel window I
know what you're looking at yeah I know
what you see what I'm dealing with right
Manny every bump in lays dealing with
everything that's fantastic I mean I got
to know have you guys ever played a game
of man against each other on Mother's
Day oh he doesn't want to get off he
doesn't say his here's the thing he
doesn't get on him alone he doesn't want
it here except the sticks in a while
yeah yeah that's what I've heard
this guy really only took the role just
so I could get Fremont PACs yo this is
true this is 100 cent true I went to
high school with one of the producers on
that and and I've been hitting him up
for years like hey I guess okay can I
get some corn can I guess
coin in-game corn here he's like my
hands inside man in my hands I'm like I
know they're not but now you got no
excuse oh I know I got it shows up a
full on of the team overall rating a 99
you're gonna be like oh that guy he's
even support alright he got you know
twenty eight billion credits and that's
all Ruby you just heard that right there
from Mike Young he's gonna have his hot
car that's gonna be on task oh I get my
muck card yeah
wait coke Cruz is gonna be a meadow see
you ready to play with the cruise
missile baby line now come in guys it's
time to bring in the game change awesome
time to bring in our youtubers we have
onto the boss I don't have I maverick
they're gonna ask the tough questions I
just gave the layups I just gave you the
easy ones these guys are gonna ask the
tough ones alright let's bring a minute
also I math come on in guys yeah Sam
yeah yeah how are you
they see you games gentlemen gentlemen
so we're all good seal what a time to be
alive all right we have a nice wide set
here that's that's we have a good base
based on our own team right yeah almost
right all right all right no math taken
away well I saw the trailer I noticed a
lot of familiar faces and I want to ask
Mike what are the stars did you work
with one creating long shot we mentioned
earlier majalis that was pretty insane
you know as before he won the Academy
Award what was cool about the role at
the time is I think we were mostly
familiar with him
being this like tough military guy and
things like Hunger Games or you know a
tough character and like house of cards
but we got to bring him in and he's
playing this father and he's and I think
everyone on set that day was like I wish
he was my dad you know he was so warm
with the children and it was a way up
until the obviously moonlight he plays a
father figure but we hadn't seen that
yet yeah which felt like wow we're
seeing a different side of him and it
was so amazing
we had the Dan Marino's the Chad
Ochocinco Wow
those days were super fun everybody was
geeked out chad johnson took everyone to
sushi
why who wants to go with me to get sushi
what there's a 40-person crew standing
around we're like what all of us he's
like yeah let's do it
I mean he had a blast that was pretty
cool I mean we had film legend barry
corbin
i mean
so many people and so many stories from
sad I was incredible I think people will
love the cast because it feels grand I
think a lot of the gaming stories feel
small like not very many characters not
many sets but I think this is an epic
story with an epic amount of places you
see epic amount of cast all just so much
variety to it women children different
80 year olds 8 year olds so it was
really cool that's awesome it's
fantastic 9 half your turn so I guess my
question would probably be for the star
is here all right boy I know it was a
four year process right putting the
other long shot what would you say was
the biggest challenge for you guys oh
man tough ones waiting they're gonna
make it waiting to get a phone call from
Mike four years ago say hey we want to
make this game in Madden and we'd love
for you to be a part of it and then not
hearing another word from anyone for
like nine months and I'm just like dude
right did he change his number I get a
text bags like sigh new phone who dis
I'm just like am I still a part of this
thing anymore and then two years ago we
get end up in Vancouver for just a week
just just jr. and I on and I walk in and
I'm like they've all you got all this
footage of other people playing our
roles like stunt guys and stuff they had
done like some test footage I'm like I
got recast the game right then I
couldn't make it down to Orlando I was
shooting something in New York and then
there's a table read nor Lando and some
guy text me cuz I went to high school in
college in Orlando and I knew this cat
text me he's like yo I'm at this table
read and I was like dick ask me again
recast me again I was just like the
waiting I'd say was like my biggest
problem was I cuz its it takes even
double the time of a movie or a TV show
like sometimes you shoot a movie or a
show and you know next year it's coming
out but with the game the cycle to build
this thing from the ground up takes so
long
it was just shifting my brain that way
I'm guys mom Oh sir but yeah Scott
mentioned the four years ago he was the
first person to verbally commit to this
thing which was great because I got to
make the script him
think about his specific talents his
personality and really custom the role
for Scott and having somebody like Scott
commit early was definitely a lot of
confidence that this thing could be real
and people are excited about it by it
and then we went on the long journey of
trying to get a green lid and all that
oh so maman isn't as deep at all oh my
biggest hurdle was getting over this dog
on camera that you have in your face oh
right look so we have an arguments in
like we forget these cameras there and
we just like claps in the cab every time
every time it clacks like we got to
start over yeah like every time you got
to start over you got to do yeah you
guys do the pose and okay that was my
biggest one okay like the have you ever
seen like the motion capture shoot where
they have in the dogs are looking at a
yeah yeah you can't put your hand in
front of your face if I want to wipe
your nose can't wipe your nose you know
so it's more changes you're doing yeah
like you want your character to rub his
eye on the scene you got to do this yeah
look we gotta like reach but not
actually touch of me there's like so
strange oh that was one of more we got
really close cuz we spent we spent in
effect you know six weeks together in
wet suits with each other for ooh it's
just me and her a bonnet it was the man
moonshining is not exciting balls all
wrestles it face makeup that looked like
we were a cats region yeah yeah way more
challenging well what's amazing about
the cast is that they are in the same
white wall white wall room every day
with these suits they don't have
costumes they don't have props they it's
all in their mind and these performances
are so believable and natural and I'm
just so proud of what these guys did and
it I think with those cameras and how
unnatural it is to have 40 people
staring at you and then these weird
outfits and all these rules on addition
to just being present in the acting I'm
just blown away by them
yeah thanks Mike
I think we all just had a moment I think
I feel like we're oldest to matter if we
can hug it out hug it out but same
emotion you'll find in long shot hey I
got a question for you guys though are
you excited about long shot I am I am
it's like the first time we've seen
something like this so I think a lot of
fans are gonna be excited as well to
play it nice right yes there's a new
experience to mattis yeah I thought
we're gonna reach a whole new audience
bring a lot of new people in and
hopefully that carries over to the other
modes as well you know the crazy thing
is about that is a lot of guys like you
youtubers and they create content online
you guys would like fake gyro making
your own store moon right right but now
you got one now we got you got one right
we got yeah you actually have a true
authentic story that goes to these guys
there's a lot of guys behind the scenes
that you got to give a shout out to as
well but you know it overall great
experience I got two things for you
though yeah you have one thing to say I
just got one thing to say and it's
important for everybody out there when
you see this and you know that Devin is
a character that you're gonna play not
everybody's Devin is gonna be the same
support week that we get the point
across everybody's gonna be able to play
Devin differently
there's branching dialogue there's
different choices the outcome of this
game you think everybody's gonna get
drafted that ain't the case man this is
serious it ain't the case so everybody's
gonna have a different path with Devin
it's not just oh I got a play as Devin
and and Colt no no no you play Devin how
you want to play them and you play Colt
how how you want to play that's that's
that's it so you still have all of that
opportunity to make your own choices
right it's fantastic stuff guys I
appreciate all you for Scott Mavs Mike
jr. on toe I appreciate it I got one
request and you're gonna have to help me
make it happen all right we have to find
the behind the scenes of them smacking
into each other with the truth we gotta
get them in the wet suits I got to see
it because we're gonna put all that
online I mean we're gonna we're gonna
find a way to do it finest news bozo
we'll make sure you look good don't you
learn it yeah let's get another one here
for the for the fans get it oh right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah let's go
he's on video yeah yep man for a guy who
started seeing himself in pictures he
takes a lot now
alright guys that is going to do it for
long shot Madden NFL 18 a story mode you
can play and right now we're going to
kick it over to the other football game
a little little football will football
send it with one good one
[Applause]
[Applause]
my team there's no
don't you see when you go through time
and never know don't show up to my show
if you've got nothing
[Music]
now that you either Hey I don't want no
bad energy man gets used by rage are cut
across see my enemy
laughter girls melon ins and melons
once a man from London
there's no crack in it I bring it on my
team you guys when they saw my team even
the bouncers bounce when they saw my
team you wanna huddle here you wanna
never know don't be a sheet when you can
be the goal great it's a good time and
you never
don't show up to my show we forgot nope
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
energy
that is right we are going from football
to football haha oh it's the hottest
game known worldwide up to the FIFA and
it's back it's bigger than ever FIFA 18
I am here with Sam and Method creative
director and the lead gameplay designer
talking about a brand new FIFA guys now
last year
FIFA 17 I can't move the world away how
are you guys doing up in Vancouver
knowing that you have to top that make
it even bigger and better this year yeah
I mean it's always what drives is right
we always want to bring the best game to
market and yell a she was a massive year
on many levels it was the transition to
the Frostbite engine which was huge it
sold over 21 million copies so a record
you across the board how that and not
bad you know and then obviously one of
the biggest things was the introduction
of the journey and I liked some to who
in just one year has become one of the
most famous names in all of football so
an incredible year all around and we
have the men in Blazers on stage we're
so hyped about Alex hunter what's he up
to
what's he good but it's not just a
hunter obviously I mean when you guys
announced the cover Stars receive 18
everybody was like whoa that was way
better than that statue that was at the
airport that looks actually like
Cristiano Ronaldo but bringing in
Cristiano Ronaldo what does that
experience just to kick like kick
starting that experience and making it
happen how did that feel once it all
culminated into what it became in seif
18 let's say well first of all it was an
awesome experience working with the best
football player in the world we went to
Madrid a few months ago to
motion-capture Ronaldo and we're putting
these animations in the game so he's
basically helping us create but it is
the biggest leap in the history of game
play so that's quite important for a
special attention in gameplay this year
so there's so many new features that I
want to tell you of a game play there's
four pillars the player the teams the
atmospheres and the dramatic moments and
let me start with the player first of
all we have a brand new animation engine
it's called a real player motion
technology it's a system that allows us
to pick animations every single frame in
the past we used to do every step the
player takes that's an animation and
with them we will just change a few
animations different steps now because
it's every single frame for the human
eye just looks like one fluid
oceans the movement of the players is
very fluid and this engine also gives us
responsiveness fluidity and personality
so you will see how the entire feature
set is about those three things
responsibilities and personality for
personality as I mentioned we're putting
Reynaldo animations in the game and now
if you look at him he runs exactly like
Ronaldo from any camera you will
recognize him right away we also have
the tools that allows us to personalize
the movement of players like sterling
you saw in the video how these hands are
a little bit oh yeah sterling is hand
like that Robin the hands more like in
this position Jordi Alba the chest up
you will see all those characteristics
in the game and we have also six new
archetypes for more personality for
every single player in the game so
before all the players would share the
same animations for running now there is
a medium sorry short medium and top
player with the skinny and stocky option
so everybody is going to have more
personality in the way they move then
there is the dribbling overhaul this is
my favorite dribbling is so much fun so
responsive and you will see a lot of
personality so you will see the players
avoiding doing all those fancy things
with dribbling just with the left stick
just by jogging for example and if you
pass the ball to somebody like Messi
he's gonna be so explosive you're gonna
see how he stretches to get to the ball
he leans he's very very very looks very
cool the visuals are very improved from
previous years and also you pass the
ball to somebody like Iniesta he's gonna
be so good at hiding the ball but he's
not that explosive so so you need the
combination of things and there's also
features for the team there is a brand
new positioning system that allows
players to coordinate between each other
to provide different types of support
all the time there's always going to be
somebody doing a safe support so you can
keep possession with a safe pass there's
gonna be people doing diagonal runs
trying to mark themselves attacking runs
and they're going to be playing closer
to the sidelines of wider
in order to create better spaces and you
can now read football like professionals
do in real life all the time trying to
read the situation you can do that
that in FIFA so we also have a lot of
play styles for example when you play
career mode you will have a different
experience so team personality depending
on what place how they do in real life
so for example we have the Tiki pack
color first and passes longbows if you
have players that are very good at
dribbling you will see I'm trying to
beat on defend there's different options
and also for the defensive side there's
quite obviously captain macho harass
there's many of them then there is the
next part which is the dramatic moments
we are changing our crossing mechanics
so now crosses are more dangerous more
driven and the Macan the actual controls
also change a little bit as well we are
improving our through-holes the shooting
system now the trajectories are closer
to the goal to give you more realistic
outcomes but doesn't mean every single
shot is going to a net and finally we
have the atmospheres which is very
important as well and there's
realization so basically depending on
where you're playing in the world you're
going to have a different experience the
lighting is different the position of
the Sun is very authentic so you have
the same experience as you get in real
at TV there's a lot of props around the
field like even cars or commercial
things banners flags like in South
America for example and there's a lot of
work on the crowds there's a lot of new
chants so you have a better audio
experience as well as the crowds not
behave individual leave so you will see
them reacting very different than before
when there is a goal for example they
will try to jump a couple of rows down
and you can actually celebrate with the
crowd you can hug them you can do many
different things the gameplay is very
very fun this year we put a fatal for
you yeah but I mean when you know
channeling all of that new newness
within a game like FIFA especially when
people have grown to expect it to play a
certain way do you guys ever I mean is
it that challenge for you guys to make
it new but still make it seem like the
players who are good at FIFA can jump in
and know exactly what they're doing and
notice the the differences that you guys
made for series all
it has to be it has to be very deep so
people learn you to be half true
people are new to FIFA they need to be
able to play it easily and then people
are very experienced they need there is
to be a lot of depth in the mechanics
but we think that fluidity is the key
this year to be to be able to have the
entertaining game for everybody that
tries to join the game and I also
understand we have a clip a little
gameplay trailer that we saw inside that
we're gonna take a look at right now
show that beautiful footage
now that you either hey I don't want no
bad energy might get fused by a charge
of the constant and
girls melons and melons she wants a man
from London
for the news
see there's no minute I'm bringing on my
team you can it's all my team even the
bouncers bounce when they saw my team
doing all of you wanna never know don't
be a [ __ ] when commuter boat great is a
good time and you never
don't show up to my soul nope
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and it's
me a spoon
for the players I mean obviously come on
I want that in my life
and obviously introducing the journey
last year I mean we talked about it
earlier
Alex hunt eyes are the most tweeted
about footballer in the history of the
world it's for like 32 million goals
lasses lose 6 million sorry ours are 360
million very nicely know what mondo
undervalued he scored over a million
goals there's no need to talk about how
many over hundreds of millions of goals
but and now we see a new iteration
absolutely the journeys continuing he's
back for his second year so he's one of
those modes well we can't really divulge
too much cuz we don't want to give it
away but now a car like this guys are
listening in there into the pitch so but
yeah we're bringing him back he's bigger
and better and we've taken him to a
wider world of football so obviously
within fee for the game we have a global
appeal with football we represent the
Glitter sport globally for the journey
one he was a lad from London so we said
it in the EPL that was his breakout year
so again without divulging too much he's
gonna spread his wings a little bit so
there's some surprises in store for Alex
and he's gonna kind of spread his wings
around the global world of football so
we've possibly not locked to England
this time so what's going on in his life
it's a tumultuous year for the for the
young lad well if you weren't one of the
21 million players who played FIFA 17
break it down a little bit about what
the journey was what you guys kicked it
off last year yeah and how you would
like to see it go from here on out yeah
so the journey was a cinematic mode
which we were able to do through the
power of frostbite so is one of the
benefits of the frostbite transition but
what it allowed us is to really kind of
give a window into the world of football
that we've never had before so we've
always done a great job of focusing on
the 90 minutes on the pitch
we've never kind of gone behind the
curtain and taken off the pitch and in
this modern world that's something that
people have an interest in you know with
Twitter you can kind of have a window
into the lives of footballers like never
before so we wanted to really bring that
that kind of what makes Football a tick
what's is you know family background all
that kind of stuff and obviously it
resonated spectacularly with the you
know
30 million people played it a whole
bunch of those completed it through
through to the end and replayed it in
many cases so it really offered has
opened up an opportunity to show a side
of football that we never done before in
FIFA and it turns away we want to take
it obviously year one was his breakout
year year two he's now a bit of an
established star what he won was
entirely up to the user so you could
have won the FA Cup you could could have
won the EPL you couldn't even got
relegated that was one of the beauties
of it it wasn't on Rails there was a lot
of choice and basically you're his
career was in your hands so we pick up
from where we left off so if you played
you only won you will start on the team
you were in he will have the personality
you created through the cinematic
moments and then we'll kind of kick it
off and I will give you a little bit of
a insight we start with him on holiday
in Rio connecting with some of the
locals which you probably imagine how he
connects with locals in real life yeah
so you know when creating that story and
cultivating all this how do you go about
creating this war for a character who's
going to be going on this journey that
you're taking him on yeah but make it
resonate with people who might have been
a professional football player or if
they just wonder what that life is like
yeah whatever they love the challenge
he's making it resonate with people
around the globe because it was set in
England so it's important that the story
is fundamentally about football and it
resonates with the football fan so even
if I'm from South America I can connect
with this story on a footballing level
and then the other part that is just
making it an interesting character just
fleshing out the character giving him an
interesting background interest in
support systems or the family they're
all back so good old granddad everyone
loved granddad he's back this second
time around mom is back so just creating
the not just an interesting character
whom you control what the support system
in the characters around him
this is key that they resonate with
users in an interesting as well and that
obviously obviously happens and what do
you think was the most crucial sort of
piece of feedback you received from
people who did complete this journey or
just from fans in general we had any
sort of comments that they made that you
were like oh yeah we should sort of go
on this route or maybe try something
like that yeah absolutely you have a
great relationship with our fans and we
value their feedback they're the most
important guys they're the ones that
play so the good news is they looked it
they really liked the resonated with the
fact that they control his personality
you know like state wasn't on Rails one
of the thing we did take from the
feedback was they wanted more big major
decisions in his lives for key decisions
that will change Alex and those around
him so keep an eye out for those very
big big decisions that you have to make
as Alex that will affect the story and
the characters and etc it again is one
of those hard things to talk to what I
don't want to spoil it here there's a
lot of Lara a lot of good stuff in there
I'm thinking like downloadable DLC a
villain character comes into his life
that villain is played by me okay I'm mo
capped in Ronaldo suit so I run like
Ronaldo I'm ripped like Ronaldo look and
it could just create some tension we're
going out on the ideas bullet I mean if
there is an ideas board I like that to
be a is right to the top what I was
thinking was well obviously a lot of
people are excited about the journey we
do have a trailer explaining what's
going down in the second part of this
journey coming in thief 18 there is one
question on everybody's lips next for
Hunza everyone's hunting hunter Alex
hunter is butyl
I think cleanliness paper talked to my
senior Alex hunter fight in the
bundesliga vanish be wisest happened at
all right under his a Robert Allen a
huge talent he needs the right Club and
the right manager any couple do like
each other
Alex hunters in the media every day and
getting annoying to be better Oh
anything
what kind of Club with let Alex hunter
go I'm not really sure that a moves are
like them stuck in your fashion but it's
got their two victories we splash
Alexander is a great player he's a piece
there she is very quick cuts to amazing
a skills intelligence I can't the
phenomena out please doc to take the
round and hunters bumpy's bread to me a
suitor for himself go go I was Miss
rumors have got a stock go Ally I like
talking I really aren't wasted side will
Alex Umstead
stay or go you sure this came out about
story to us
does your heart tell you
[Applause]
Cole
[Music]
yes for the players alright everyone so
we've been talking so much about some
fantastic EA games here at EA play 2017
but y know it's really fantastic some
battlefield baby that's right
we're gonna have some battlefield 1
action I'm golden boy joined by Andrew
Golota one of the guys working on this
incredible game as well as my homeboy My
partner in crime when it comes to these
events Wes see how you doing man a
little too bad how are you fantastic I
can't wait it's I mean we're gonna see
some awesome stuff with battlefield 1
yeah in fact you know what Andrew let's
just let's just jump into it what are we
gonna see today well today we're gonna
take a look at Nivelle Knights
this is a first Knight map for about a
third one okay Night Man yep now what
are some of the challenges with Knight
maps in particular that you you found
when you were making the game like where
you were making you know these maps so
obviously the first thing that comes to
mind is lighting right you don't want to
be in complete darkness where you can't
see your opponent you want to be able to
view your opponent and get a good shot
off so it's really finding that fine
balance they're really getting in making
sure that you can be strategic so we
want to be able to make sure that you
could also find dark corners and hide a
little bit get where you needed to go my
place I'll oh yeah just hide in a corner
the tiny border just snipe right that's
yeah I'm doing no I just wait with a
shovel you know you're the shovel guy
yeah back ahead oh I roll I see what
about you how do you play well I try to
stick to a saw I'm more of an infantry
player so that close-quarter setting
which you'll see in a minute yeah is
definitely something that you can focus
on on this new map having a played it in
the testing environment you're going to
see some good close quarters game yeah
the trench the trenches play really well
here yeah they do play really well and
there's some interesting differences
between the two trenches that I think
we'll talk about later on in the Ryan
can't wait I can't wait to share it so
many details put into this now had a
chance to play this before in the test
server yeah um was it as detailed as it
is here or people gonna see some new
things that they haven't seen before if
they play it in the server yeah so in it
on our CTE the community test
environment it was in it's kind of pre
phase pre alpha phase so you're going to
see a lot more details so it's really
refined making sure the artwork
as polished as possible the gameplays as
polished as possible so you might find a
few little areas for cover that you
probably didn't have on the CTE okay I
like that I like that a lot it you know
it's very exciting because I think what
a lot of people thought about World War
one and it's exciting for some and for
others it's also concerning which you'll
see in a little bit they have nothing
being concerned about because everyone
thought World War one trench warfare
right now must be so boring and
obviously you guys didn't do that when
the game first came out but now you are
bringing into the trenches right what
were some of the challenges in making
that combat feel exciting well when you
think of World War one trench warfare
it's one trench on one side one trench
on the other yeah and you wait right
who's going to storm the other and then
the guys who get up out in into the open
they're the ones that die first but this
what the way we we win about it is we
wanted to create a no-man's land in
between both trench sets so this created
we put a lot of cover and a lot of
interesting spaces where you can even
have some really good combat outside of
the trenches but once you go in the
turns and the corners and all the little
nooks and crannies tons of fun happening
all right well without further ado let's
go ahead and jump into it Neville Knight
here and this is again you know this map
looks incredible if you guys haven't had
a chance to check it out here at EA play
the oh man you're gonna you're gonna be
in for a treat here Wesley what do you
have from your buddy just wanted to say
straight up you might notice we're
playing the conquest game mode but its
own both sets of teams have got two
captured flags already and then in the
no-man's land in the middle that's where
you've got to neutral uncontested claps
yeah that's something really unique to
this we wanted to make sure that the two
flags were that were in your point are
the plaques you already own we thought
it'd be really weird if you had to
capture the flags that were already in
your trenches okay
think that you guys are experimenting
here this one or is it something that we
could potentially see in other maps as
well yeah I think that Europe you might
be seeing some more of this in the
future yeah cuz it's a little weird
right to like start the game off and
you're like okay well we know what we're
gonna get all right so you might as well
just get to the action quicker right by
just giving it giving those those two
spots there and it also makes that
encounter a bit more intense for for
seeing D cuz you want to be able to push
a light in the middle yeah the no-man's
land as you guys had mentioned before
okay so take a look oh my goodness just
got absolutely shredded on that one
Bangi just did all the work on that I
think we're on board with Stone Mountain
here and we are in the middle of no
man's land heading towards dead steel
and you might just be able to see over
to the left as he goes over the hill
here you see the massive shell of a char
to see for healeth there that's been
added in recently I think yeah so what
you're seeing now is the remains of a
shelling right what happened in this
time this is this is based on Nivelle
offensive where you had a shelling
attack on the German front and and this
is what we're seeing this is the results
you're fighting with in the midst of
that they're doing their absolute best
to be able to maintain control here of
see you get dead steel lock down wonder
what stones gonna wear he's gonna send
us shoots all there they're looking to
push forward you're looking to push
toward B to take B okay I like that
Stone Mountain unit 64 on the move when
he's gonna find someone in front of him
nice kill there on qjb take a seat Bob
and man well it's interesting that he's
decided to go for the B point rather
than going for the other no man's land
flag so what he's essentially saying to
his troops is look let's take their
trench line and force the issue onto
them because as we said they were
already captured for that team anyway
and they've decided to just go straight
for it and take those flags and stuff
this is exciting because you know the
players right now you have to make a
decision I mean if I'm you know on this
squad I'm I'm thinking okay well if we
need to brush we we have to get a little
aggressive we have to you know do our
absolute best here to kind of maintain
our positions and you know the German
forces they they only have two flags at
this moment meanwhile on the other side
of the French they're dominating they
are dominating at the moment and
actually as we were watching Stone
Mountain they're going for some of the
the enemy trench lines we ended up
seeing that the two objectives that they
run away from and they don't get it
taken by the enemy team so the whole map
sort of flipped itself on its head for a
minute here's this on your screen here
sorry miss I love Cronin not miss Alan
Charlie follow the title crime in the
tank wait who's every tank out right now
yeah look in front of the view see the
delay in that you also got a little
activity in the trenches down there as
well that player knew that he was in a
real bad slot so we had to get out of
Dodge as soon as he possibly could then
one of the things I do like about this
with the trenches is you know there is
that it's all right there miss just
through the the need over go through the
allocate right like you'll never know it
right in the trenches yep anybody feat
hiding behind those corners oh boy mugs
ended up getting kicked off there the
Lighting's really interesting in the
trenches here actually because you've
got some points that were very well lit
it's just certain parts and if you go
into the straight narrow trench moving
towards the next bit of light you've got
almost nothing in between so you're just
seeing the outlines of players off in
the distance yeah what in what's left of
the
kind of like those those spaces well
let's talk about the lighting because
there is a distinct difference between
the French and German side right when it
comes to the lighting yeah so this is
really an interesting part of the map we
took a lot of interest in creating a
differences between the sides and with
the way we did that what you'll see is
there's quite symmetry in this map the
way we did that to change it up is how
the lighting played a big role so we
made one side the German side you'll see
a lot of electric lights
so you'll see service lights you'll see
a lot of light bulbs and that's gonna be
a good indicator that you're on the
German side of the map so that's is
actually quite true the history to what
we saw was the Germans buckled down they
fortified their their trenches and
that's why they survive this attack and
then the French side is gonna be a lot
more again you got a fires you got
flames keeping it keeping it lit and
everything's kind of wood and it's all
it's all very organic on that side
almost feels like it's a little bit more
I've been made in a hurry like it was
like I've got to make this now before
the Germans make that book a friend
generally didn't have a lot of time no
well what we saw too is that the French
kind of thought that the the Nivelle
offensive was going to be a big a big
win they were they did the shellings and
they thought this is gonna be a so they
weren't in it for the long haul but they
proved to be wrong yeah one of the
things I really enjoyed about VF 1 when
it came out and we're still seeing it
today it's weak I feel like we have a
new generation of history buffs who have
emerged because of battlefield one like
people who are genuinely into the
history of World War
yeah because it is it's the Great War
but there is so there's so many stories
to tell and things that people just
don't really know about which is makes
it very you know guessing encapsulating
right it makes you want to learn more
but yeah you know we're gonna check out
some sniper game today man doom 49 don't
let us down buddy get those shots all's
yeah he was able to get an enemy hit
they're giving him any points he's just
gonna continue to march down here toward
me getting ready for the Danzig train
branch I'm looking for him to take off
some faces here it'll be pretty tough if
you'd be able to do so and they have
four points right now so they are
marching down the battlefield no pun
intended
I'm sorry it's actually very interesting
because if you look at it looking all
that was a nice shot there that was
lovely but if you look at the points
inside oh it's good on the street
oh no oh he would've gone that shot
through the trees I would have just put
this Heather down walk away but yeah if
you look at even though the teams are
slightly imbalanced on their flags at
the moment the actual score between the
two is very very close yeah and [ __ ]
maybe it's just the fact that when this
was all organized them it we're gonna
make this really even on both teams no I
know right call it a bayonet charge
there Oh didn't pay off for him I think
he missed his target gamers snack with
the pickoff there Paul what are your
thoughts yeah Wesley sorry answered the
horrors Wes di I think to your point I
think that because this is a foul
map it's a very symmetrical I think that
this is that's what makes this really
easy math to kind of have those valence
again but yeah because I mean looking at
it but the structure of it almost with
the trench sides being very similar yeah
you've almost got that that feeling
constantly anyway you've got that
British quick I'm out of here
that's right you've got that feeling a
bit being very balanced from the start
and it's just depending on whether your
team communicate properly whether uses
one leader function to make sure that
you're covering your own objectives and
then attacking like another single or
maybe two objectives at once and then
that balance can remain but if you
decide to go too far forward and push
too much and don't cover the flags that
you currently own then the enemy team
could get in those trenches are very
hard to get them out yeah absolutely I
look in the hole down here on the in the
front line and say
report of such so you got four to five
buildings around you and good cover as
well and high ground advantage as you
can see x-factor taking advantage of
those opportunities when he sees fit
this guy man he is a fantastic
battlefield player and also a great
youtuber as are all of these creators
here freak streamer as well it happened
to tune into his twitch streams quite a
bit but mugs mugs manages to find him
but luckily for him pony line was there
on the pickup he's not just a pilot he's
a great man ahead as well that's what
you're looking for an emetic yeah you
need somebody to come and revive your
players that's the thing man good town
playing a squad and my team they always
abandon me
then again I do tend to like run out all
the way out and play Road field yeah you
know it's like follow me you know get
the hint dog like just come with me and
we'll win the whole game you'll that
lone wolf got a plot oh yeah I'm the
worst kind I what I do typically those I
happen to attain and then I just drive
around as much as I possibly can and
destroy people speaking of that how many
tanks can you get on double night so
there's one tank on each side okay
that's the plan here we wanted to keep
it pretty infantry focused so once you
start going too heavy I mean you're
gonna get some some cavalry as well okay
so that's where that's where you're
gonna get a little bit quick gameplay
but we wanted to dis a very infantry
focused I think that's really good
because obviously you've got these
trench lines that's for a reason right
you want the trench lines to be utilized
yeah so if you gave the loads of vehicle
suddenly everyone's not using the
trenches that you built right and
especially because you've built a lot of
the objectives around the trench lines
the only other two were the ones in
no-man's land in the middle yeah and
then and that's why there's no no planes
in here as well right we don't want you
having fun right yeah just that it
really takes away from it that's not
yeah okay you're in a trench like what
more can you yeah I can hold out we all
know how that goes
oh boy here we go dogs looking too good
dude look at the destroy support don't
believe fantastic sniper man I want my
guns a lot and he'll have two crates I
don't have to go with the secondary and
that's the cold it's a curse that is we
said he was sorry and you give him all
the compliments they never pull through
it always happens that way always
revived there it is I love it there you
go
March on down X Factor you're done this
is one of the the new weapons that's
just been introduced as well that you
guys introduced in was it the visit of
May or the spring update I think you
added a few new variants yeah we had
some variants that we introduced in the
May update yeah so this is the how
spring update here's me I think isn't
spring up dude
this is the hell regaled offensive which
is yet an optical sight 120 round drum
magazine Mike ever need that many bullet
well you know you really want to spring
praise that's you and it's also got the
bipod as well so I guess if you wanted
to set it up behind cover and literally
as as the weapon when you label prone
you are gonna be hearing a little more
accurate let's see see you think of it
look at this spread on the bullet - you
see the way that they're just really
going like a tight order yeah which is
fantastic like that's certainly one to
see here that the good I paid off you
took all felt that yeah
nice he's gonna try and charge in here
oh there it is this is hell working
there we go the one and only a dankness
four to nine he hates that name but I'm
gonna keep seeing it every time here
you'll pop some smoke get some cover
yeah it's interesting again here because
we're on board with the who are we on
board they were on board with the French
army and they're taking back the flags
that they had at the start of the round
right and as you can see at the top
there from the the flag layout they are
sort of fairly defined in terms of the
flags that got out of it well that's all
there are you here but they're ahead on
score so the Germans need to pick up a
little bit
looking around here darkness issuing
doze issuing dos borders but because you
can be blessed one yeah there we go
there it is so they're now gonna capture
their second objective shoot him in a
row trash all lovely tight down there
vex outer darkness man telling you
change the name hidden things on there's
there's miss Ella Cronin way I
mistakenly called missile a little while
ago but she's flying through the
trenches like a missile oh there you go
but I got it you got to bring it back so
now it's that worried that works one in
front
Wow looking for that Nukem dukkha man
where's your awareness on Humble the
dude in 49 one and only I think he's top
dragon on his squat there we're on his
hole on the whole team as a matter of
fact after look at that yet again on the
on the topic of lighting andreas Archer
question because battlefield one has
some dynamic weather in it
Azrael does leave out lights have the
same kind of dynamic weather the other
maps do no we're not going to see any
storms or Eddie's hand or anything like
that okay this takes place on the on the
in French soil or on French soil so so
it's going to be kind of what you see
here we feel like the night is really
kind of what's where we're we're we're
we want to create that atmosphere yeah
yeah I mean the the darkness itself
gives it a lot of coverage and imagine
adding anything more into that could be
a little bit difficult but we on board
with here think it's doom 49 so that all
we takes the shot so darn ice though
they're young had to like you said
I showed up okay dude it worked right it
played good played real well well I do
want to mention that we haven't seen it
yet and I hope I hope one of our game
changers managed to make it happen but
what about the elite kit man I wanna see
some flandro action I do too roasting
some fools in the trench I do too
this is also a great opportunity for
maybe a trench Raider we have the trench
right oh this one I think we might be
seeing that it would be only fitting to
have a trench Raider with a trench map
that's a very good point
he's fine with it with the red chicken
with the French pact I mean this is an
extension of this pasty see on this map
here so we really I think we should see
if they can pick one up by the way can
be coming on how close this game is
right now for 34 42 for 31 but it seems
like the German Empire they're starting
to rally the troops and capture all the
bases all their base belong to the
Germans Empire and they are dominating
right now this seems pretty true to
history I think yeah I mean that even
have the truth the Frenchy to find a way
to fight this one back they all taking a
dump they are taking a couple of the
flags back actually you can see a lot of
them are actually up for contention
you've got a de and F well now de in our
contention yeah but as you can see
they're all being taken by the enemy
team as we're watching so it may come
down to a point where we're looking at a
lot of flags being taken by one team and
not being held by the others we're seing
a lot of combat here in the no man's own
right yeah and we just need to see
people coming towards the flag
concerning to Capitol Hill points
because as much as the trenches can be
very lethal when you run round the
corner or maybe get hit with a shotgun
you know they do provide a lot of cover
at the same time if you know no one's in
that trench you can take cover in it
yeah it's a great place to chuck a
grenade as we saw earlier yeah but it is
hard though right to determine that so
many turn so many corners you just never
quite know what you're gonna find and by
the way miss Ella is just rushing it up
well there you go again you just did it
just you know Andrew gave the curse I am
over the mugs now once again sniping
from another club shooters that he's
using the labelled sniper which is the
French c-54 so sorry I missed it some of
those flick shots but I mean how do you
do that yeah I'm just like I sit in or
watch people who could slide the video
and just a credit person no they are
like two of my favorite snipers watch on
Twitch whenever they're streaming
because they are so unbelievably cool to
do this gun but oh no mugs taking a lot
of shots to the left though he's gonna
have to dive right into the trench get
you know yeah let me get him back to
Carter well I can see the pliers up on
the hill over the far side that's who
he's looking for
he's gonna meet Brett affect everything
oh there we go lights you know I cited
climb here oh I can see that kinda guy
she's taking a hit shot oh all it takes
heat just literally all he has to do is
breathe on him and bugs will fall here
so hahaha he's got to be very careful oh
there is a pathogen good night good shot
there
bugs looking to do it again there you go
didn't even need this a gun all you had
to do is take a bullet and then throw it
at mugs and then bugs what if would have
died is on that alone now - looking to
is a best bugs impression here look at
that school now the friendship pulled it
all the way back round I can't believe
it
this is family filled out it's fine it's
actually a really good game oh it's so
close
impressive stuff here we're storming
dead still here the a looks like we're
heading in that direction
he's one of the tanks this is x factor
of a 1 and over later just annihilating
this is what I love to do personally you
can see this tank can go over and weed
out all those little yeah you know
cretins there in the trenches oh yeah
okay you want to be careful not to fall
into the trenches he probably would have
fallen at this moment right it's the
splash damage potential he's got here
just firing it against the wall waiting
for the infantry okay Hannah oh oh he's
it oh he's in so still managed to move
around cam here but I think there's
going to be some really tight spots but
we also have cavalry in there yeah
because we everyone's in that it's
impossible whole kitchen sink is it
possible to get out of the trench
network what Idol I'm thinking now oh
wow wait oh my see something this guy
created let's see what week it is gonna
work oh oh he's not Wow
I mean Russ going through the trench
eyes you're going although limpets come
into the tank that was like you gave me
a believer he like ran away he saw that
no that's the CC 24 so the tank it was
like oh boy oh boy
that was not going well we didn't we she
would go for the limpet kill yeah I know
those guys they would go for the limpet
of kill oh my goodness
gonna sit for the repair right here so
there's oh oh they're storming they're
starving Oh
doing he I think he's stuck I mean II
look at these absolutely legit oh well
hey I think he knows he's stuck too and
rule number one is never leave your
vehicle yep so we might see a really
boring game here I disagree I think this
is awesome
any kills they got always knows what
they're all trying to think about here
we go he's well off we've got this all
wet we popped up a little bit what you
need to try to do is get to one of the
richer level here we go you yummy that
there we go climb up oh I'm up somebody
need to know
get behind the tiger oh well I guess
absolutely not gonna happen if you could
get to one of the rear trenches it
doesn't move it out go get around back
yeah there might be a way yeah oh yeah
and we're gonna see it yeah victory nod
right here so happy back of a man's land
where it feels comfortable yeah a male
bone room gets out at that moment and
then just gets bombarded oh that would
have been amazing
I was very battle it was very low Lucy
because if you left the tank not only
could be any of enemy team could have
got in it but if it had elected another
Titan would live sport yes so he's kind
of left the shell yeah about that
below kind of drench yourself he was
very good for getting it you know I like
that you're finding the positive there
last Hospital Westie that's what all
right find the positives and the
negatives but just update everyone on
the score I mean this is a really cool
game really Cooper 658 645 the action
continues to rage on here tickets are
still coming yeah we have 9 minutes and
45 seconds left in these in this game
and we hope you guys are enjoying it
once again if you're just joining us
here you're tricking out Neville Knights
in a new map that is gonna be coming to
Battlefield one it is the first night
map that this game has and it is awesome
yeah and it's coming later this month
later this month I am so excited and
also the the other map as well you ever
used it to her because I can't pay that
much that one I've had to practice for
yeah I hope I'm saying you're right
finchy guys just call it like you know
like darkness well that would have
worked right it would have been fitting
oh man
speaking of Darkness we're going over
the team darkness here with bugs tv5 1
in front of them that got to kill fill
up that's never mind skilled down for
you sir oh oh very good that was a nice
one that's what I do you know that's why
they pay me moderate dollars they keep
coming oh they got the hit was going for
that awful torso shot thankful I land it
he was on for a head shot that's what
you were hoping for the duck or
something bugs only goes for the face
it's just
he operates would you say it would be
only for the bug only for the bug oh
yeah like a sir you should become a
commentator a new man reached I cannot
be as good as you guys do this more
often
I love it alright waiting around here
mullet we're playing in no-man's land
here a lot of the gameplay that we've
seen has been it's known as that
connection but we haven't seen some
really good trench in there
I think it's typical of the conquest
game mode where agains the constant
movement head low yeah
so if you if you leave your own trench
you go into no-man's land an objective
and chances are the enemy team Swain
trail behind you - taking one of the
observatory's oh that and I run I found
my biggest success is usually when I'm
trying to go one or two points
I can't even with you right now mugs I
know you guys are trying to like talk
about how great I was having trying to
be strategic about this this is how you
do it this is what you having ribbons
left and right you just go through any
shred period man let's take D I hope he
can take this you're just renamed
himself a blender white Oh land that
shot he was going to show and suppress
by that fly already landed it straight
in the chest sky man he is just
absolutely incredible because were in
the chapel here the ruins looking for
the next go whoa
headshot oh is that a headshot I don't
know though it was close you want dead
mojo good I can't believe the shots he's
getting he's just getting assistant
there counting his kills cuz they're
like why would push why not well he's
trying he's finishing it off there we go
I think it was one more left Tomita
always switch kits switched out to the
support kit he was probably running out
of ammo there make it look good players
I will do that I haven't I haven't run
out of ammo before yeah yeah but that's
like uh how does me hold on
oldest trick there it is there it is
that was a trend trader kill what if he
was doing I couldn't see the name of who
was actually running the church raider
here we got stone man following horse
this is great unit 64 himself
unfortunately we're not in a trench but
we are taking cover here this is gonna
be a good one I'm going out
the ruins so this was I haven't had a
chance to tinker around with the trend
trader yet yes so fun is he super quick
all melee so you're running you have a
little extra help because you have this
armor on it yeah it is just all-out war
this guy runs around Oh makes him deadly
straight ready one-hit kills get ready
you can memory if you can let it go
I'm hoping this is something believe in
yourself so no don't get shot leave him
alive oh there's one Jehovah sorry buddy
could have oh gosh oh you can tell shark
then really oh I'm more like a land fish
oh man he'll spit help oh he's out east
oh my goodness hey beautiful that was
good so well that was good at was
Della's fun he knew the pressure was on
him he heard us in the venue so huge
yeah I got show up right now the screens
on me absolutely three kills in a row
that was worth it yeah definitely the
Touring traders like one of those
counter-attacks though because it's like
you've got to take only go your mailing
looks like you do have the revolver but
it's not it's not the same as
non-semantic apartment so I mean hope
someone here killed but you really want
to use that guy yeah definitely and it's
like if you know there's a couple of
players around the corner you know
you're good enough health care a minute
to get your health I just stalled
Stormin yeah yeah actually gonna win by
the way guys an update five minutes left
in the game 5 minutes 17 seconds we
exact and it is still a close of fair
between these two teams
8:28 to 8:30 9:00 and the points just
keep on ticking we're on board right now
with darkness 4 to 9 an incredible
twitch streamer by the way via get ever
get a chance to check him out all these
guys once again I said it before I'll
say it again amazing creators that we
have here at EA play looking to just
have some fun and also show off with
some great gameplay on the new map
Neville Knight coming very soon next
month no coming this this month oh this
one very
you know what we haven't seen yet what
we have to see ditch no one has actually
called in for Anna artillery strike you
can clear it artillery to do that how do
you know that
wait you don't get a tell us Lu I think
we should see if anyone can figure it
out yeah I can't go into it well if it
doesn't happen by the end of the game we
should jog yeah those are the games
start off with a artillery strike though
in the middle of the map so you do have
a little bit of that just kind of set
the mood the mood keep you doing the
point yeah I like that I like that quite
a bit of prevents everyone from like
going nuts and just charging trains in
the middle like a bunch of crazy people
and it also adds like a little bit of
like story and feet are me eyes yeah I
mean that's too young that and that's
what this is all about but will if
you're almost into my score at the
moments are you real but but there's no
tickets in it it is literally a tie
school eight so far no clothes yeah but
if you're not we ties for soon we are
going to the time to see you guys know
so so three minutes 50 seconds 50
seconds okay and this cook this game
cream coffee any closer if we tried I
swear we did not rehearse this this
happened last year a games come as well
both games went down so quiet it did
that's right happens every time we do
this and so happens when you get a bunch
of good players in one room and just
have them Duke it out man hundred
percent doom here with [ __ ]
shaaka oh ho oh yeah
that's got to hurt yep you heard the
scream you knew it was coming oh yeah
it's on its way
yeah well that's funny cuz he's like
looking around he's like it's gonna buff
me or is it the globe guy and then
there's no brain in front of you going
through your kidney here I guess that's
a good point of the vertical gameplay
that you're gonna get here oh he was in
behind go where man and he was a target
as soon as our shooting you just
especially with the dark matter and the
way that it's played out the muzzle fire
you really see then you can tell and
again that's where the lighting really
plays a role in this game and what
you're able to do yeah really finds
those nice dark corners but what you're
also gonna see when they start sniping
is goes on the hilltops those
silhouettes that are moving you see the
movement fight away and that's great
because over the back you have some was
like some AI elements OD yeah
interesting 2 minutes 25 seconds the
9:24 will end anywhere here yeah the
gaps opened up just a tad those rocky
gonna come all different like damage
that was a deflect second right engine
disabled could he finish it on there
which I know it's gone beautiful just go
for a stone just shoot and believe in
yourself man
then shoot into the darkness at the
ratios blowing time to charge
I know right well they are gonna be able
to overtake seat both teams have three
flags but the seeds even like our swamp
so spike to see a lot of activity who's
gonna be able to win out that battle in
the midfield is the question Stone
Mountain rallying with his team forward
shooting his teammate because reasons
and it's over to a and they're going all
the way out to the other side of the map
for that last-ditch effort here Andrew
son Isaac is I hope we see some
something incredible here they have to
cap at least two in order for them to
come back into this one idea one minute
and 23 seconds because it's not sure
it's what happened yeah no I won't have
we're down they are capturing two points
I can't see it happening personally I
think it's gonna go the biggest no I
think three ticket nah they're not gonna
do this not gonna do it not gonna happen
gonna be real tight let's see if see if
it happens to resupplying like over to a
thousand and that's right as a matter of
fact it was two thousand but I don't
think you know I mean we figured we were
gonna make it there or til the game
ending either way though they needed to
stop literally everything from happening
and that was not the case team darkness
will reign supreme
oh boy what a what a match yeah well
it's kind of fitting too cuz it was a
dark matter I have to say well you know
let's go ahead and take a look at some
of the highlights from that game because
it were a metric crap-ton from that game
man I have to say uh
June 49 had a couple great shots as well
as mugs mugs I think was a superstar
this whole game though she's getting
shot
shot after shot here is absolutely
tearing it up I mean like if watching
mugs do some of that it's just it's not
it's sometimes so even the accuracy it's
a continued accuracy beyond the first
shot like first or second or third every
single shot left
yeah credible only about a thermometer
in there yeah and here's the thing
that's not just marketing to me that is
like actual yeah thank you you know you
get these crazy moments in this game
because of the open nature of it right
that's what you lent it to the super
dynamic yeah this is the stuff that
drives us when we're making you games we
want to make sure we provide these these
ways to create this building and I'm
particularly glad because as a person
really enjoys infantry combat combat I
like that this map really highlights the
infantry combat it's a lot of fun
yeah right you know the gun mechanics in
battlefield are fantastic I want to be
able to take advantage of it as much as
possible and you know do what they hear
yeah you know so awesome stuff all
around you have to say and yeah I mean
what's he thoughts on the map I think
the maps are really really good because
it's the first night map very different
from anything that you've created so far
the lighting really lends itself to a
different style of gameplay you can see
that the trench close-quarters action
yes you can't get a somewhat on some
other maps but because of the nighttime
setting everything's a little bit closer
together so it's much more chaotic yeah
we saw a lot of close quarter combat
here yeah I loved it it was awesome
I liked the close quarters combat once
again but I think that's something that
we're all gonna kind of echo here
because it's very yes you have it in
other maps but it's just a different
feeling it's a different tone I really
feel like you know if I had to think
about how be if one would do full-on
trench combat that is admittedly how I
would want it to be so glad to hear that
yeah and I'm glad I'm glad that it was
able you know it was nailed right
cuz when I lay this I'm gonna be super
into it because I just came to trenches
hide a corner shotgun some fool hit him
with a pan just awesome stuff well you
guys leave hands uh you know it might
come up now that you've recommended I'm
leery got on the list well yeah every of
the designers revelation is here dude
I'm telling you man I I'm a great game
designer kind of sort of not really
alright guys well awesome time here but
for now though let's go ahead and send
it over to Jose who's down on the floor
Jose what you got for me buddy hey guys
I'm hanging out here with miss Ella
Cronin who I was bothering trying to get
an interview with the end of that round
that's why our team sort of fell behind
so I feel like it was my fault I
apologize but tell us a little bit about
your experience with Neville Knights and
how you think it's going to affect the
battlefield one players out there it's
really fun like the the nighttime aspect
and the fact that it's dark and so much
hard to see what's going on completely
changes that miss fair so yeah no it's
really different it's like a completely
different experience and how do you
approach the night maps as compared to
the typical daytime or desert like maps
that we've seen in battlefield before I
mean I like being a medic anyway so I
tend to stand a little bit further back
from the fights and just try and heal
and keep people alive
so yeah this hasn't really changed I
kind of can like hang back try my best
to keep my team alive keep my school
other lives yeah that was it difficult
to approach being a medic when the when
the lights are out it's nighttime
Neville Knight's shining down all you
see is the Sun lights the twinkle of
lanterns does it make it harder for you
to sort of find your teammates or do you
just sort of rely on your icons it does
it does make it harder but it also makes
it harder for them to see me which I
quite like so it works out both ways
hey smart thinking that's how it's done
uh well I'm sorry I see your team has
left you again to play some more I will
let you get back to playing thank you
miss Ella Cronin back to you guys at the
table replacement overnights awesome
stuff there I
that was Missal herself that is some
missile cronin no miss Ella Cronin she
was at how fantastic medic throughout
this game we caught a couple good clips
of her really you know just keeping
everyone going and that that is
essentially what a medic and easy to
wrap just yep don't you know cuz you got
those medics okay we think like oh I'm
just gonna heal myself no that's not
what you're supposed to do okay you're
actually supposed to you know like like
kill your teammates see you Butterfield
squad game that's right
ah we supplied and revived resupply and
revive I loved it I had such a good time
man Westie what a day what a day yeah
it's been really good book we're not
quite finished oh there's one more thing
that we've got left coming ok there's
been a really special video has been
made by
of our battlefield community members
we're going to flick over to it now and
we hope you enjoy it
[Music]
Wow
at least my hand
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a battle pack ladies and gentlemen
thank you Dan Jeff you guys are doing so
good nice carry this battle pack all the
way out here
mugs what's this what's this this is a
this is a very special battle pack for a
very special woman you know we met at
twitch through twitch through
battlefield we've done so much with the
community it has been an amazing you
know experience with you and I just you
know I want to share it with you for the
absolute rest of my life and Evelyn
Raines would you marry me yes yes can I
get three oh yes on three one two three
yeah she said yes in case you guys
missed it there was a nod but there was
a verbal yes you won't be able to find
that battle packing game oh battle pack
is naughty
not at all my friend congratulations to
people who I know very well who are
absolutely incredible human beings bugs
into Lala you guys are awesome
congratulations and I'm glad that you
were able to do this surrounded by your
friends who are also your family and
thousands of people online as well the
battlefield community is truly amazing
and incredible they've welcomed me in
with open arms when I first got involved
and they do so with everyone else so big
thank you to you guys what a time what
did that this was fun
that it was pretty I had a good
community all right guys well once again
just want to close it out here
congratulations
mugs a lot you guys deserve it and you
guys are going to have a happy life
together but for those of you guys want
to have a happy time playing some
battlefield metal nights will be coming
off pretty soon as well that will be
this month so be on the lookout for that
but that's going to do it for us here
it's been a great time you know playing
some battlefield
still so much more to come at EA play
and of course to Andrew and for Wesley
thank you so much
glad to be here this is a good time
happy to be potted all right well we'll
catch you guys on the other side
[Music]
you